STATE SENATOR HOLLY MITCHELL
FROM THE THIRTY DISTRICT AND
IT'S MY PLEASURE. TO GAVEL DOWN
AND CONVENE THE FIRST HEARING.
OF THE TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
LEGISLATIVE SESSION OF THE
SELECT COMMITTEE.
ON THE SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF
CHILDREN'S HEALTH.
YES THAT'S A MOUTHFUL.
AS YOU HEAR ABOUT WHAT WE INTEND.
TO TALK ABOUT --
AND BE EXPOSED.
TO UNDERSTAND WHY WE'VE CHOSEN
THAT TITLE.
I SEE WE HAVE TRANSLATION
SERVICES HERE TODAY.
SO I'M GOING TO TRY TO BE
MINDFUL TO SPEAK SLOWLY.
AND IF AT ANY POINT.
YOU NEED TO REMIND ME WAVE YOUR
HANDS.
BECAUSE NATURALLY I MUST BE
TALKER.
SO AGAIN GOOD AFTERNOON WE IN IN
OUR THRILLED TO SEE SUCH A HUGE
TURN OUT HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM.
SENATOR PAN WE HAVE TO OVERFLOW
HEARING ROOMS IN THE BUILDING
WHICH YOU KNOW IS NOT EASY TO DO
ON A ON A SECTION DAY.
AND THEY'VE GOT A JUMBO TRON
OUTSIDE ON THE WEST STEP TO
PEOPLE OUTSIDE ARE ABLE TO VIEW.
SELECTED MY HAT --
TO ALTHOUGH SPOKE RABAL TO MAKE
THAT HAPPEN WE THANK YOU.
WE WANT TO GIVE A SPECIAL SHOUT
OUT TO THE CENTRAL VALLEY POSSE
WHO'S HERE TODAY AT THE CAPITOL.
I WANT TO WELCOME YOU TO YOUR
STATE'S CAPITAL --
WE UNDERSTAND WHAT IT TAKES TO
GET TO SACRAMENTO VERTICALLY
THIS TIME OF YEAR AND I KNOW YOU
TWO BUSES EARLY IN THE DAY AND
THE RAIN WAS NOT IN OUR FAVOR.
BUT YOU ARE SHOWING YOUR
COMMITMENT AND YOU DID YOUR
ADVOCACY THAT A LITTLE RAIN
DIDN'T RAIN ON YOUR PARADE WE
THANK YOU FOR COMING.
WE HAVE A FULL SELECT COMMITTEE
HEARING.
IN TERMS OF MEMBERSHIP THE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE ARE --
SENATORS BATES.
CABALLEROHER TITLE BACK TO PAN
INTO THE RUBIO.
THIS IS A HEARING DAY AND SO YOU
WILL SEE PEOPLE COME IN AND NOW
I DON'T WANT YOU TO BE OFFENDED
BY THEM COMING AND GOING IT'S
JUST THAT WE HAVE. FIVE THINGS
TO DO ALL THE SAME TIME AND SO
OF BY VIRTUE OF THE FACT THAT
THEY'RE ON COMMITTEE THEY'LL BE
TRACKING YOUR TESTIMONY AND
KEEPING UP WITH WHAT YOU'RE
DOING.
THE PLANS FOR THE SELECT
COMMITTEE AGAIN THIS IS THE
FIRST WHEN WE LOOK FOR QUITE
FRANKLY TO TAKING THE SHOW ON
THE ROAD WE'RE GOING TO TRAVEL
THROUGHOUT THE STATE IN AREAS
WITH THE HIGHEST POVERTY RATE.
AND SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES SO WE
OF LEGISLATIVE CAN LEARN MORE
ABOUT THE PROBLEMS COMMUNITIES
FACE AND WHAT MIGHT BE DONE TO
SUPPORT YOU.
SELECT COMMITTEE THEY'RE AN
IMPORTANT TOOL WE HAVE THAT
ALLOW US TO DISCUSS ISSUES MORE
IN DEPTH AS OPPOSED TO JUST WAIT
IN AS A AYE OR NAY ON A PIECE OF
LEGISLATION.
SO WHY THE SOCIAL DETERMINANTS
OF HEALTH.
AS A LEGISLATOR WHO'S WORKED --
IN THE BUILDING FORMERLY A STAFF
BUT NOW THE SENATOR.
I THINK THAT WE ALWAYS BRING OUR
BACKGROUND EXPERIENCES TO THE
TABLE WHEN WE ACT.
SO FOR ME IT WAS A NO BRAINER
WHEN I HAD A CONVERSATION WITH
OUR FIRST WITNESS TO TALK ABOUT
WAYS IN WHICH WE COULD DELVE
MORE DEEPLY.
INTO THE ISSUES THAT LEAD TO
CHILDHOOD POVERTY.
OUR NEXT HEARING I'M PROUD TO
SAY WILL BE IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY IN JULY.
AND WILL FOCUS ON HEALTH ACCESS.
IN THE FALL WILL DO A THIRD
HEARING ON IMMIGRATION IN LOS
ANGELES.
AND NEXT YEAR WE INTEND TO FOCUS
ON ENVIRONMENT EDUCATION POVERTY
M. LAND YOU.
OF COURSE TODAY'S HEARING WILL
FOCUS ON THE ROLE HOUSING PLAY.
IN ONE'S ABILITY TO BE HEALTHY.
WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO OPEN THE
FLOOR AND ASK A DOCTOR PAN TO
BRING READING.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH CENTER
MITCHELL AT YOUR MITCHELL --
I REALLY WANT TO THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR CONVENING THIS SELECT
COMMITTEE ON SOCIAL DETERMINANTS
OF CHURCH CHILDREN'S WELL BEING.
AS A PEDIATRICIAN AND A FATHER I
KNOW HOW THE SOCIAL DETERMINES
ART TO NOT ONLY CHILDREN'S WELL
BEING BECAUSE CHILDREN BECOME
ADULTS.
AND SO THAT BECAUSE THAT'S
REALLY ABOUT THE WELL BEING OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE I'M
VERY EXCITED TO BE INVITED TO BE
A MEMBER OF THE SELECT COMMITTEE.
AND VERY MUCH LOOKING FORWARD TO
THE WORK THAT THE SELECT ME IS
GONNA BE DOING BUT ALSO TO
RECOGNIZE YOUR TREMENDOUS
LEADERSHIP.
IN THE LEGISLATURE ON ISSUES
AROUND CHILDREN I WANT THANK YOU
SO VERY MUCH THERE MITCHELL FOR
THAT.
AS IS YOU MENTIONED
UNFORTUNATELY --
I HAD THIS IS A HEARING DAY I I
DO CHAIR OF THE SENATE HEALTH
COMMITTEE AND WE HAVE AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON PUBLIC
HEALTH --
THAT ACTUALLY SHOULD START
SHORTLY SO I I'M GOING APOLOGIZE
IN ADVANCE THAT I'M NOT GONNA BE
ABLE TO BE PHYSICALLY PRESENT
FOR MOST OF THE REMAINDER OF THE
HEARING.
HOWEVER I DID WANT TO BE SURE I
WAS PHYSICALLY HERE FOR THE
BEGINNING OF THIS HEARING IN MY
CERTAINLY MY STAFF.
AND I WILL BE FOLLOWING THE
REMAINDER OF THE HEARING AS WELL
AS THIS IS THIS IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT DISCUSSION IS IS
HAPPENING HERE TODAY.
AND SO AGAIN I WANT TO THANK YOU
SO MUCH THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
HERE AND AGAIN WHAT THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP.
AND CONVENING THE SELECT
COMMITTEE THANKS FROM A CENTER
THANK YOU VERY MUCH START TO PAN
AND DOES THIS GIVE ME AN EXCUSE
ABSENCE FROM HEALTH COMMITTEE
TODAY.
OKAY THANK YOU.
THAT'S RIGHT THAT'S RIGHT THAT'S
RIGHT WE HAVE TO GET EXCUSED
ABSENCES SINCE WE'RE NOT GONNA
BE WHERE HE IS THANK YOU --
DOCTOR PAN I APPRECIATE YOU AND
YOUR RIGHT THANK YOU.
EXCELLENT WE'VE ALSO BEEN JOINED
BY -- MY NEW
COLLEAGUE IN THE STATE SENATE
SENATOR SUSAN RUBIO.
THANK EVERYONE FOR BEING HERE OF
COURSE I WAS AN EDUCATOR FOR
SEVENTEEN YEARS --
AND DAD CHILDREN IS SOMETHING
THAT I PRIORITIZE ALL THE TIME
AND SO THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING
INVOLVED IN AND BEING HERE TO
SEE HOW WE CAN MAKE.
LIFE BETTER FOR CHILDREN THANK
YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR TO RUBIO --
WE'VE GOT DIFFERENT MIKE'S HERE
TODAY BECAUSE WE'RE BEING --
RECORDED --
SO THAT.
I'M NOT GOING TO GIVE FULL
INTRODUCTIONS OF EITHER MEMBERS
OF THE SELECT COMMITTEE OR
SPEAKERS BECAUSE YOU SHOULD HAVE
THEM.
AND THE DOCUMENTS THAT WERE MADE
AVAILABLE THAT ARE OUTSIDE I'M
ASSUMING WITH ALL THE HEARING
DOCUMENTS --
BUT YOU SHOULD SEE THE GENDER
OUR EXPECTATION TODAY.
IS TO HAVE FIVE PANELS.
UNLIKE A TRADITIONAL COMMITTEE
HEARING WE WILL OPEN IT UP. FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE END OF THE
HEARING OF THOSE OF YOU THIS IS
YOUR FIRST HEARING.
MAKE NO.
AT THE END OF THE HEARING ALL
CALL FOR PUBLIC YOU'LL SEE
THERE'S A MICROPHONE THERE THAT
THE SENATE SERGEANTS WILL DIRECT
YOU TO AND THAT WILL BE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR YOU.
TO COMMENT ON SOMETHING YOU'VE
HEARD ALL IN TODAY'S COMMITTEE
HEARING TO PROVIDE US WITH YOUR
PERSPECTIVE.
WE HAVE. FOUR PANELS WE'RE GOING
TO BEGIN WITH A GOLDEN STATE FOR
ALL.
AND MISTER HEWITT OUR FIRST
PANELIST MISTER HEWITT IS THE
PRESIDENT AND CEO.
OF THE FEAR HEALTH FOUNDATION A
PHILANTHROPIC GROUP THAT IS
WORKING ON PROMOTING HEALTH
EQUITY IN UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES.
MISTER HEWITT YOUR RECALL THAT
WE WERE STANDING IN THE FOYER OF
YOUR VERY BUILDING I GUESS A
LITTLE OVER A YEAR AGO.
WHEN WE TALKED ABOUT HOW WE
COULD PARTNER --
TO ELEVATE THE ISSUE OF NOT ONLY
CHILD POVERTY WITH WE BOTH
WORKED ON FOR MOST OF OUR
PROFESSIONAL CAREERS BUT TO
REALLY TALK ABOUT IT FROM THE
CONTEXT OF REGION'S RECOGNIZING
THAT --
CALIFORNIA IS A VERY DIVERSE
STATE AND SO WE WANT TO TALK
ABOUT THE POCKETS IN WHICH
CHILDREN ARE EXPERIENCING
DISPROPORTIONATE LEVELS OF
POVERTY.
ARE THAT CONVERSATIONS GROWN THE
SELECT COMMITTEE AND I'M PROUD
TO PARTNER WITH YOU TODAY AND
I'M GLAD THAT YOU'RE HERE TO
JUMP START IT THANK YOU FOR
COMING.
AND THE SUN REPAIR MAN I HAD THE
GREAT PRIVILEGE OF WORKING WITH
TWO OF YOU ARE HERE TODAY
LOOKING FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU IN THE FUTURE.
AS WELL.
THIS IS THE INCREDIBLE
INCREDIBLE DAY FOR US AND IT DID
START WITH A CONVERSATION I MEAN.
GREAT THINGS CAN HAPPEN
SOMETIMES JUST PASSING ONE OTHER
IN THE HALLWAY --
WHEN YOU HAVE FOLKS WHO ARE AS
COMMITTED TO ISSUES AROUND
CHILDREN?
AND LEVY A NEW EFFECTS OF
POVERTY --
AND TAKE THAT WORK.
AS SERIOUSLY AS IT SHOULD BE
TAKEN GIVEN THE IMPACTS OF
ACTUALLY HAS ON THE GROWTH AND
DEVELOPMENT OF OUR YOUNG PEOPLE
AN IMPLICATION THAT HAS FILE
GREAT STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
IS NOT.
SOME INNOCUOUS CONDITION.
WE'VE BEEN VERY PROUD OVER THE
PAST DECADE TO BE FOCUS ON THE
SOCIAL TERMS OF HEALTH.
NOW WE KNOW WHEN WE SUPPORT A
LOT OF WORK THAT'S FOCUSED ON
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE.
WE KNOW THAT HOW IMPORTANT THAT
IS WHEN ONE IS ILL OR SICK OR
YOU'RE TRYING TO PREVENT THOSE
THINGS FROM HAPPENING.
BUT WE ALSO KNOW 285% YOU HEALTH
HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH YOUR BILL
ACCESS HEALTH CARE.
IT'S ABOUT THE PLACES YOU LIVE
IN THE OPPORTUNITIES YOU
ACTUALLY HAVE.
AND WE AS A FOUNDATION OF FOCUS
MOST OF OUR ENERGIES.
IN THAT REGARD.
AND SO I THOUGHT WITH THAT TODAY
JUST TO GIVE YOU A SENSE OF WHO
WE ARE.
YOU KNOW PART OF OUR WORK IS
ALSO ABOUT BRINGING COMMUNITIES
AND THEIR IDEAS AND OUR
ASPIRATIONS ABOUT A FUTURE THEY
PREFER TO BE AS MUCH AS WE
POSSIBLY CAN.
AND SO TODAY IS OUR EQUITY ON
THE MALL WHICH IS SOMETHING THAT
WE'VE DONE FOR THE PAST FOUR
YEARS WHERE WE BRING COMMUNITY
TO THE CAPITAL. TO ALLOW THEM
THIS YEAR WITH YOU THEIR STORIES
VERY OUR AND THEIR HOPES FOR THE
FUTURE. FOUR YEARS AGO WE
STARTED THIS SEVENTY PEOPLE
JOINED US. THREE YEARS AGO WE
HAD A THOUSAND LAST YEAR IT WAS.
FIFTEEN HUNDRED TODAY OVER TWO
THOUSAND PEOPLE OUT ON THE WEST
WALL THE DISTRICT WHERE A
CAPITAL --
WAITING HERE AND SHARING YOUR
IDEAS --
WOULD LEGISLATORS ABOUT WHAT
THEY BELIEVE NEEDS TO HAPPEN
GOING FORWARD AS RELATES TO
CHILDREN A GREAT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AS RELATES TO
COMMUNITIES AND FAMILIES.
AS WELL.
I CAN'T UNDERSCORE THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE WORK ENOUGH.
NO CALIFORNIA IS AN INCREDIBLE
STATE NOW I MOVED HERE AS A
YOUNG MAN.
MADE AT MY HOME --
AND NO LEFT TO MY OWN DEVICES
THIS IS WHERE THEY WILL PUT ME
TO REST WHEN THAT TIME COMES AS
WELL.
I LOVE THE STATE.
ASSN CREDIBLE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD WE ALL KNOW
THAT.
BUT ALSO HAS THE HIGHEST POVERTY
RATE IN AMERICA --
AND WE THINK THAT THIS IDEA TO
CALIFORNIANS.
IS SOMETHING WITH ALTHOUGH WHICH
WISDOM INNOVATION AND I THINK ON
A MORAL FORTITUDE THAT'S BEEN
DISPLAYED BY LEADERS IN THE
STATE IS SOMETHING THAT WE CAN
DO AWAY WITH.
IS A SOCIAL CONSTRUCT THAT NEED
NOT HAPPEN.
THEY NEED NOT BE REAL.
THIS IS THE REALITY THAT WE
CONTROL.
WHICH ALSO MEANS THE REALITY
THAT WE CAN CHANGE.
AND SO WE ARE EXCITED NODDED TO
BE PARTING WITH ALL OF YOU. TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO DO THAT.
ALL EXPECTATIONS IN OUR
PARTNERSHIP WITH THIS.
SELECT COMMITTEE OF FALLS INTO
THREE CATEGORIES.
VERY HAPPY WILL BE ABLE TO FOCUS
ON SOME SPECIFIC ISSUES AND
TODAY WE'LL BE TALKING ABOUT
HOUSING AND ITS IMPACT ON THE
WELL BEING OF CHILDREN.
WE THINK THAT THE FUND THAT WILL
BE ABLE DEEP UNDERSTANDING ABOUT
pWHAT SOME OF THE CHALLENGES ALL.
BUT ALSO TO MOVE THAT TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT SOME OF THOSE SOLUTIONS
COULD POSSIBLY BE.
AND THEN LASTLY TO KIND OF BUILD
THE KIND OF CONSTITUENCY THAT
ELECTED OFFICIALS WHO ARE.
WILLING TO WORK HARD TO DEAL
WITH TOUGH ISSUES NEEDS IN ORDER
TO MOVE AN AGENDA.
FOR THIS ABOUT MOVEMENT BUILDING
FOR US IS ABOUT EMPOWERING THOSE
WHO OFTEN ON EMPOWER.
ALLOWING THEMTO HAVE THE SAME
HOPES AND ASPIRATIONS AND DREAMS
AND ACCESS TO THE MECHANISM THAT
MAKE THOSE THINGS REAL.
THAT MOST OF US WITH GREAT A
PRIVILEGE HAVE THAT'S WHY WE ARE
HERE TODAY.
I COULD RATTLE OFF A LOT OF
STATISTICS THAT ON MY SHEET IN
FRONT OF ME.
ABOUT THE CONDITIONS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND I COULD TALK A LOT ABOUT THE
CENTRAL VALLEY WE HAVE FOCUSED
OUR WROTE ONE IN FOUR SCHOOLS
YOU CAN'T DRINK THE WATER.
NOT TELL YOU A QUICK STORY THAT
I ACCOMPLISHED WITH A COLLEAGUE
IN FLORIDA.
WHEN WE TOLD HER THE STORY SHE
WANTS A FOUNDATION?
FOR WHEN WE TOLD A STORY SHE
ACTUALLY THOUGHT THAT WE WERE
BEING UNTRUE.
ACTUALLY STILL RELY.
A COMMENT TO ME WAS IN THE GREAT
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
I CANNOT BELIEVE THAT THE HEART
OF THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND WITH
TECHNOLOGY AND YOU KNOW ALL THE
WONDERFUL THINGS WE ABOUT
CALIFORNIA.
THAT THERE COULD BE A REGIONAL
PLACE WHERE KIDS COULD NOT DRINK
THE WATER SCHOOL.
WE'RE EXPOSURE TO PESTICIDES AS
HIGH AS IT IS IN THE CENTER OF
OUR WE'RE RATES OF ASTHMA WILL
GOING ON ADDRESS.
THAT WAS NOT THE CALIFORNIA SHE
KNEW.
SHE LIVES IN FLORIDA.
BUT NOT THE KIND OF IDEA THAT
SHE HELD IN AHEAD.
ABOUT WHAT WOULD LIKE LIFE WOULD
BE LIKE. FOR FOLKS WHO ARE NOT
WEALTHY.
AND I CONSIDER TO BE OVERLY
INFLUENCED.
BUT WHO WERE RESIDENTS OF THIS
GREAT STATE.
THAT YOU WOULD NOT HAVE TO BE IN
THOSE TWO CONDITIONS.
IN ORDER TO GET THE THINGS THAT
WE CONSIDER TO BE BASICS IN
ONE'S LIFE.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE HERE TO
REALLY LOOK AT AS I SAID TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND.
AND THE CHANGE.
WE ALSO ON THE BALLOT HOUSING.
OVER TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
THOUSAND KIDS ON A DAILY BASIS
ARE HOMELESS AND CAL.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO
CHANGE.
WE KNOW THAT IS NOT NOTION OF TO
CALIFORNIA'S IS SOMETHING THAT
HAS BEEN.
DOCUMENTED IN ANY NUMBER OF
PLACES.
NO I'LL GREAT HOPE TODAY IS THAT.
WE MOVE BEYOND THE STUDIES AND
THE DOCUMENTATION WHICH WE KNOW
WAS IMPORTANT --
TO A LEVEL OF ACTION AN ACTIVITY
WHICH WE KNOW WAS A SECTION.
WE KNOW THAT. FOR THOSE OF US
WHO WANT TO DO AWAY WITH THIS
IDEA OF TO CALIFORNIA'S.
THAT WE FEEL TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUES.
OF CHILD POVERTY THIS NOTION.
OF OF GOLDEN STATE.
FOR CAN NEVER BE CHEAP.
THAT WILL BECOME NOT THE GREAT
REALITY.
IN CALIFORNIA.
BUT THE GREAT MYTH [inaudible]
ABOUT CALIFORNIA.
IN THE SAME WAY MY COLLEAGUE IN
FLORIDA COULD NOT BELIEVE THERE
WERE SCHOOLS.
WHERE KIDS CAN BATTERY?
FOR SO MY RATE ASK OF YOU TODAY.
IS THAT WE CONTINUE TO PARTNER
IN WAYS THAT REALLY IS ABOUT
MOVING AGENDA.
FOR AND I KNOW.
THIS IS NOT.
NO SPEAKING TO REQUIRE ALTHOUGH
MY MOM ALWAYS TOLD ME THAT CHECK
THE WHY GO TO CHURCH FOR REASON
TO TO JUST THINK THIS THING SO.
IT'S JUST A TO SING.
WHAT THE ALLOW US?
AND IN THE US I MEAN NOT JUST
THE PHONE PROPERTY.
BUT THE COMMUNITY AT LARGE.
SO VERY DIFFERENT CROWD YOU SEE
IN THIS HEARING TODAY.
IT'S A VERY DIFFERENT RATHER YOU
TYPICALLY SEE OUT ON THE WEST
STEPS OF THIS PARTICULAR CAPITAL
OF THIS GREAT STATE. TO REALLY
PARTNER WITH US TO MOVE AN
AGENDA FORWARD THE MAKES THIS
NOTION OF CALIFORNIA BEING OF
GOLDEN STATE FOR ALL.
REALITY.
NOW CONCLUDE MY REMARKS WITH
THAT THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER HEWITT YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT --
THE CROWD WE SAW SOME OF THE
WEST AFTER HEARING HIM IN THE
HEARING OOM CERTAINLY LOOKS
MORE LIKE CALIFORNIA.
THEN THEN IN MANY INSTANCES ARE
SYMBOL WE APPRECIATE YOU ON AND
THE WORK OF YOU AND YOUR BOARD
OF DIRECTORS ARE AT THE
FOUNDATION FOR MAKING THIS
POSSIBLE.
NEXT I'D LIKE AARON.
CLEARLY INTENDED PARTNER IF YOU
WE'VE COMMITTED TO GO TO THE
CENTRAL VALLEY IN JULY IN THE
MIDDLE BY SUMMER BREAK YOU KNOW
WE'RE DOWN FOR THE FIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
[inaudible] FOR ME. FOR
EVERYBODY OKAY.
THEY'VE HEARD YOU LOUD AND CLEAR
[inaudible]
SENATOR SKINNER.
WE'RE ONLY USING THESE MIKE'S
NOT THOSE MIKE FOR NOT WORKING
SO IF YOU HAVE A QUESTION I'M
COULD YOU DON'T HAVE TO I WILL
BUY FEWER PEOPLE WILL BE HERE
NEXT TO ME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THAT NEXT.
WE'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM DOCTOR
MARGOT.
COMMERCIAL COMMERCIAL.
THANK YOU CRUCIAL.
THAT'S A CRUCIAL DIRECTOR OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SAN
FRANCISCO CENTER FOR VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS.
HER RESEARCH FOCUSES ON THE
CAUCUS ON THE CAUSES AND
CONSEQUENCES.
OF PHARMACISTS AND HOUSING
INSTABILITY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR COMING
AND WE WILL MAKE SURE THAT WE DO
A SOUND CHECK.
THAT THEY CAN HEAR YOU.
SURE EXCELLENT THANK YOU.
Q. SENATOR MITCHELL SENATOR
RUBIO SENATOR SKINNER --
THANK YOU FOR INVITING ME TO
COME AND SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY MY
NAME IS DOCTOR MARGOT COULD SHOW
AND I'M A PROFESSOR OF EDICINE
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
SAN FRANCISCO AND THE DIRECTOR
OF THE UCSF CENTER FOR
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS.
I'M A PRACTICING GENERAL
INTERNIST AT ZERO BURKE SAN
FRANCISCO GENERAL HOSPITAL AND
TRAUMA CENTER THE PUBLIC
HOSPITAL OF THE CITY AND COUNTY
OF SAN FRANCISCO.
AND I'M ALSO AN NIH FUNDED
HEALTH SERVICES RESEARCHER WITH
SUBSTANTIAL EXPERIENCE
RESEARCHING HOMELESSNESS AND
HEALTH.
BEFORE I BEGIN MY REMARKS I WANT
TO SAY A FEW WORDS ABOUT WHY I A
PHYSICIAN WHO PROVIDES CARE FOR
ADULTS.
IS HERE TO TALK TO YOU TODAY
ABOUT THE NON MEDICAL DRIVERS OF
HEALTH FOR CHILDREN.
I'M HERE TODAY BECAUSE MY
RESEARCH AND CLINICAL WORK HAS
SHOWN ME THAT I CAN HAVE A FAR
LARGER INFLUENCE ON MY PATIENTS
HEALTH.
BY FOCUSING ON THEIR SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH THEN I
CAN BY PROVIDING MEDICAL CARE.
OF COURSE I BELIEVE HIGH QUALITY
MEDICAL CARE IS IMPORTANT I
BELIEVE DEEPLY AND PROVIDING
ACCESS TO HEALTHCARE FOR ALL.
BUT THE TRUTH IS TO MAKE THE
LARGE ON HEALTH AND WELL BEING
WE NEED TO FOCUS OUR ATTENTION
ON THE SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF
HEALTH.
WELL IN MY CLINICAL PRACTICE I
CARE FOR ADULTS AND NOT CHILDREN.
I CAN TELL YOU THAT THERE'S NO
BETTER WAY TO ENSURE THE HEALTH
OF OUR COMMUNITY CHILDREN'S IN
ADULTS TOGETHER THEN TO WHO
ATTEND TO THE NEEDS OF THE
CHILDREN.
AS WE LEARN MORE ABOUT THE
LIFELONG DEVASTATING EFFECTS OF
TOXIC STRESS ON CHILDREN'S LIVES.
WE BETTER UNDERSTAND THE NEED TO
CREATE THE CONDITIONS TO PROMOTE
CHILDREN'S HEALTH AND WELL BEING
ONE OF THE BEST WAYS TO DO THIS
IS BY ADDRESSING THE SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS.
THE WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION
DEFINES A SOCIAL DETERMINANTS AS
THE CONDITIONS IN WHICH PEOPLE
ARE BORN GROW LIVE WORK AND H..
THE CIRCUMSTANCES ARE SHAPED BY
THE DISTRIBUTION OF MONEY POWER
AND RESOURCES.
UPSTART I WILL DO THAT.
SOCIAL DETERMINANTS THE NEW
YORKER IN ME I'M SORRY VISUAL
DETERMINANTS INCLUDE THINGS LIKE
SAYS YOU ECONOMIC STATUS.
EDUCATION.
NEIGHBORHOOD AND PHYSICAL
ENVIRONMENT EMPLOYMENT SOCIAL
SUPPORT NETWORKS AS WELL AS
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE WELL MANY
EFFORTS TO INCREASE HEALTH AND
HEALTH EQUITY HAVE FOCUSED ON
CHANGING THE HEALTH CARE SYSTEM.
THE SOCIAL DETERMINANTS CAN BE
MORE CAN DO MORE TO CREATE
HEALTHY CHILDREN AND ADULTS.
HEALTH CARE ACTUALLY CONTRIBUTES
RELATIVELY SMALL PROPORTION TO
OUR HEALTH.
IT'S ESTIMATED THAT OUR GENETIC
MAKEUP CONTRIBUTES 30% TO OUR
OVERALL HEALTH.
INDIVIDUAL BEHAVIOR 40% SOCIAL
AND ENVIRONMENTAL FACTORS 20%.
AND HEALTH CARE 10%.
HOWEVER EVEN THIS UNDERSTATES
THE TRUE IMPACTS OF THE SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS.
THE ENVIRONMENT IN WHICH WE LIVE
HAS PROFOUND INFLUENCES NOT ONLY
ON OUR HEALTH BEHAVIORS.
BUT ALSO ON HOW OUR GENES ARE
EXPRESSED AND WE KNOW THAT
STRESS RELATED TO THE
ENVIRONMENT IN THE EXPERIENCES
THAT WE HAVE IN IT HAS PROFOUND
EFFECTS ON BOTH THEIR BEHAVIOR
AND OUR GENES.
ENSURING FULL ACCESS TO HIGH
QUALITY HEALTH CARE WILL HELP.
BUT ENSURING THAT PEOPLE HAVE
ACCESS TO STABLE AFFORDABLE AND
SAFE HOUSING.
HOW FULL AND AFFORDABLE FOOD
SAFE PLACES TO EXERCISE AND PLAY?
ACCESSIBLE PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION
AND HIGH QUALITY SCHOOLS MAY BE
MORE IMPORTANT TO ENSURING
HEALTH.
AND WELLNESS.
I WANT TO FOCUS MY REMARKS ON
THE ROLE THAT SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING HAS IN
ENSURING HOUSE.
WE NARROW FROM DECADES OF
RESEARCH THAT HOUSING
INSTABILITY AND HOMELESSNESS
HAVE DEVASTATING IMPACTS ON
HEALTH.
THIS IS PARTICULARLY TRUE FOR
CHILDREN.
AS DOCTOR MACK DOES MANDA
SOCIOLOGIST SAYS IN HIS
GROUNDBREAKING WORK EVICTED
WITHOUT STABLE SHELTER.
EVERYTHING ELSE FALLS APART.
IN THE UNITED STATES OVER HALF A
MILLION PEOPLE HALF A MILLION
PEOPLE ARE HOMELESS EVERY NIGHT.
ONE THIRD OF ALL PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS ARE
PART OF A FAMILY WITH YOUNG
CHILDREN. ONE IN FIVE HOMELESS
PERSONS IN THE UNITED STATES IS
A CHILD.
FAMILIES EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS OUR YOUNG FAMILIES.
APPROXIMATELY HALF OF THE
CHILDREN.
LIVING IN HOMELESS FAMILIES ARE
UNDER THE AGE OF SIX ONE IN NINE
ARE INFANTS LESS THAN A YEAR OLD.
IN FACT THE MOST COMMON AGE IN
WHICH A PERSON IS LIKELY TO STAY
IN A HOMELESS SHELTER IN THE
UNITED STATES IS AN INFANT LESS
THAN. 112% OF THE NATION'S
HOMELESS FAMILIES WITH MINOR
CHILDREN LIVE IN CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA HAS THE SECOND
HIGHEST NUMBER OF HOMELESS
FAMILIES IN THE U..
WITH AN ESTIMATED TWENTY ONE
THOUSAND PEOPLE EACH NIGHT BEING
MEMBERS OF HOMELESS FAMILIES
[inaudible]
FAMILIES EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS
CAN BE INVISIBLE TO THE PUBLIC.
THEY ARE HIDDEN.
HIDDEN AWAY IN HOMELESS SHELTERS.
DOUBLED UP IN CROWDED AND
UNSTABLE CONDITIONS WITH FRIENDS
OUR FAMILIES.
LIVING IN THEIR CARS IN
ABANDONED BUILDINGS ARE IN HOTEL
ROOMS.
BUT THEIR LACK OF VISIBILITY
DOES NOT PROTECT THEM IN ANY WAY
FROM THE TERRIFYING RISKS OF
HOMELESSNESS.
WHEN WE THINK OF HOMELESSNESS IN
CHILDREN WE THINK OF BOTH
CHILDREN LIVING IN FAMILIES WHO
ARE MOSTLY GOING TO SPEAK ABOUT?
BUT WE ALSO THINK ABOUT
UNACCOMPANIED YOUTH YOUTH AND
YOUNG ADULTS AGED TWELVE TO
TWENTY FIVE WHO EXPERIENCE
HOMELESSNESS WITHOUT A PARENT OR
GUARDIAN.
APPROXIMATELY 11% OF PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS ON ANY
NIGHT OUR UNACCOMPANIED YOU.
WHILE MOST ARE BETWEEN EIGHTEEN
AND 2512% ARE UNDER.
EIGHTEEN CALIFORNIA HAS THE
HIGHEST NUMBER OF UNACCOMPANIED
YOUTH EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS.
IN A SINGLE NIGHT IN JANUARY TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN THERE WERE
OVER TWELVE THOUSAND
UNACCOMPANIED YOUTH EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS IN CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA FOR ACCOUNTED FOR
OVER HALF OF ALL ON SHELTERED
HOMELESS YOUTH IN THE UNITED
STATES.
UNACCOMPANIED YOUTH FACE
UNPARALLELED RISK THEY ARE
HIGHER RISK OF SEXUAL
TRAFFICKING OF SURVIVAL SACKS OF
SUBSTANCE USE AND VICTIMIZATION.
THEY FACE EXTRAORDINARY RISKS OF
DYING FROM VIOLENCE OVERDOSE AND
SUICIDE.
UNACCOMPANIED HOMELESS YOUTH ARE
SOME OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE
CITIZENS.
TURNING BACK TO FAMILY
HOMELESSNESS.
THE PRIMARY.
SING NEEDS MEANS THAT A
HOUSEHOLD IS LOW INCOME SO THEY
MAKE NO MORE THAN HALF OF THE
AREA MEDIAN INCOME.
DOES NOT RECEIVE ANY HOUSING
BENEFITS LIKE HOUSING CHOICE
VOUCHERS AND SPENDS MORE THAN
HALF OF THEIR HOUSEHOLD INCOME
ON RENT.
FAMILIES WITH CHILDREN ARE THE
LARGEST GROUP OF AMERICANS WITH
HIGH WORST CASE HOUSING NEEDS.
35% OF ALL HOUSEHOLDS WITH WORST
CASE HOUSING NEEDS ARE FAMILIES
WITH YOUNG CHILDREN.
THIS NUMBER HAS BEEN RISING AND
CALIFORNIA HAS SOME OF THE
HIGHEST RATES OF WORST CASE
HOUSING NEEDS IN THE COUNTRY.
FAMILIES WITH CHILDREN ARE
ACTUALLY AT THE HIGHEST RISK OF
ADDICTION.
THEY'RE MORE LIKELY THAN
HOUSEHOLDS WITHOUT CHILDREN TO
REPORT DIFFICULTY PAYING RENT
AND THEY'RE TWICE AS LIKELY TO
FACE EVICTION.
THIS IS PARTLY BECAUSE
HOUSEHOLDS WITH CHILDREN HAVE
DIFFICULTY BALANCING WORK WITH
CHILD REARING AND THEY'RE MORE
LIKELY TO FACE LEAST VIOLATIONS
DUE TO CONCERNS ABOUT
OVERCROWDING NOISE DAMAGE OR
SIMPLY COMPLAINTS ABOUT
CHILDREN'S BEHAVIOR CHILDREN
BEING CHILDREN.
EXACTLY.
THEY FACE ADDITIONAL BARRIERS
WHEN LOOKING FOR NEW HOUSING AND
FREQUENTLY HAVE TO MOVE IN WITH
OTHER FAMILIES OR MOVE TO LOWER
QUALITY HOUSING OR MOVE TO
DISTRESSED NEIGHBORHOODS.
EVEN IF THEY DON'T BECOME
HOMELESS THIS CAN CREATE MANY
HARDSHIPS INCLUDING DISRUPTIONS
IN WORK FOR ADULTS IN SCHOOL FOR
CHILDREN.
FAMILY VIOLENCE IS A VERY
FREQUENT PERCENT FOR TENT OF
HOUSING LOST.
MORE THAN 80% OF CHILDREN WOMEN
WITH CHILDREN WHO ARE HOMELESS
HAVE EXPERIENCED INTERPERSONAL
VIOLENCE.
AND WE KNOW THAT PARENTS WHO
HAVE EXPERIENCED MORE ADVERSE
CHILDHOOD ADVANCE WHEN THEY WERE
CHILDREN ARE AT HIGHER RISK OF
BECOMING HOMELESS AS ADULTS.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT OVER THREE QUARTERS OF
PEOPLE EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS
IN FAMILIES IDENTIFY EITHER AS
NON WHITE OR IS WHITE LIGHT NEXT.
OVER HALF OF PEOPLE EXPERIENCE
IT IN FAMILIES EXPERIENCE
HOMELESSNESS IDENTIFY AS BLACK
AMERICANS.
THIS IS ALMOST FOUR FOLD HIGHER
THAN THE GENERAL POPULATION AND
TWICE AS HIGH AS A
REPRESENTATION OF BLACK
AMERICANS LIVING IN POVERTY.
IT IS SIMPLY IMPOSSIBLE TO DISK
MEREKA.
WITHOUT DISCUSSING THE INSIDIOUS
ROLE THAT RACISM PLAYS IN
CONTRIBUTING TO IT.
PRIOR TO BECOMING HOMELESS
CHILDREN IN HOMELESS FAMILIES
ARE AT HIGHER RISK OF HAVING
EXPERIENCED THE DEVASTATING
EFFECTS OF POVERTY FOOD AND
SECURITY PARENTAL DEPRESSION IN
FAMILY VIOLENCE.
THESE MAY CONTRIBUTE TO THE
TERRIBLE EFFECTS OF HOMELESSNESS
ON CHILDREN'S HEALTH.
HOMELESSNESS IN CHILDREN HAS
BEEN LINKED TO A MYRIAD.
OF NEGATIVE CHILD HEALTH
OUTCOMES [inaudible]
INCLUDING ASTHMA [inaudible]
LEAD POISONING.
RECURRENT INFECTIONS OBESITY
DENTAL PROBLEMS DEVELOPMENTAL
DELAYS AND MENTAL HEALTH
PROBLEMS.
MORE THAN A QUARTER OF HOMELESS
CHILDREN REPORT HAVING WITNESSED
VIOLENCE.
AND MORE THAN HALF A REPORTED TO
HAVE ANXIETY OR DEPRESSION.
FAMILIES EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS ARE MORE LIKELY TO
INTERACT WITH THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM THAN POOR FAMILIES WHO
ARE HOUSE.
HOMELESSNESS INCREASES THE RISKS
FOR CHILDREN BEING PLACED OUT OF
HOME.
THESE SEPARATIONS CONTRIBUTE TO
MENTAL HEALTH PROBLEMS INCLUDING
ANXIETY DEPRESSION POSTTRAUMATIC
STRESS DISORDER AND CONDUCT
DISORDER.
HOMELESSNESS DIRECTLY AFFECTS
CHILDREN'S ABILITY TO HAVE
STABLE SCHOOLING.
IT AFFECTS EDUCATIONAL
ATTAINMENT AND IS ASSOCIATED
WITH LOW LITERACY.
CHILDREN WITHOUT STABLE HOMES
ARE MORE THAN TWICE AS LIKELY TO
REPEAT A SCHOOL GRADE.
HAVE HIGH ACTIONS HE ISM DROP
OUT OF SCHOOL OR BE SUSPENDED OR
EXPELLED.
CHILDREN IN HOMELESS FAMILIES
ARE LESS LIKELY TO HAVE REGULAR
HEALTH CARE.
DESPITE THEIR HIGHER NEEDS THEY
LACK ACCESS TO PRIMARY CARE
DENTAL CARE AND MENTAL HEALTH
CARE AND THUS ARE MORE LIKELY TO
USE THE EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT AND
TO BE ADMITTED TO THE HOSPITAL.
HOMELESSNESS IS DEVASTATING TO
HEALTH FOR BOTH ADULTS AND
CHILDREN AND THERE IS SIMPLY NO
MEDICINE AS POWERFUL.
AS HOUSING.
SO WHAT ARE THE BEST STRATEGIES
TO RESPOND TO FAMILY
HOMELESSNESS THE FAMILY OPTION
STUDY WHICH WAS LAUNCHED IN TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHT WAS A
RANDOMIZED CONTROLLED TRIAL TO
DETERMINE THE EFFECTIVENESS.
AND RELATIVE COSTS OF DIFFERENT
INTERVENTIONS TO ASSIST FAMILIES
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS.
THEY LOOKED AT LONG TERM HOUSING
SUBSIDIES SUCH AS HOUSING CHOICE
VOUCHERS.
PROJECT BASED TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING.
UP TO TWO YEARS OF HOUSING IN A
BUILDING WITH EXTENSIVE SUPPORT
SERVICES.
COMMUNITY BASED RAPID RE HOUSING
OR TEMPORARY RENTAL ASSISTANCE
FOR UP TO EIGHTEEN MONTHS AND
SERVICES THAT REALLY FOCUSED ON
FINDING PERMANENT HOUSING.
AND USUAL CARE.
FAMILIES DID NOT GET ANY
PRIORITY ACCESS IN USUAL CARE.
BUT COULD USE ANY AVAILABLE
SERVICES.
IT IS RARE THAT WE HAVE SUCH
RIGOROUS RE RESEARCH ON TOPICS
REGARDING THE SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH.
THE FAMILY OPTIONS STUDY
PROVIDES INSIGHT INTO BOTH THE
F. FAX OF FAMILY HOMELESSNESS
AND THE DEVASTATING EFFECTS.
OF HOMELESSNESS.
THE FAMILY OPTION STUDY RANDOMLY
ASSIGNED TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
HOMELESS FAMILIES INCLUDING MORE
THAN FIVE THOUSAND CHILDREN.
IN TWELVE COMMUNITIES INCLUDING
ONE IN CALIFORNIA TWO ONE OF
THESE FOUR INTERVENTIONS.
FAMILIES WERE ELIGIBLE IF THEY
HAD STAYED FOR AT LEAST A WEEK
AN EMERGENCY SHELTER.
THE STUDY TRACKED THE FAMILIES
FOR MORE THAN THREE YEARS TO
ASSESS OUTCOMES RELATED TO
HOUSING STABILITY FAMILY
PRESERVATION ADULT AND CHILD
WELL BEING.
AND FAMILY SELF SUFFICIENCY.
THE USUAL CARE GROUP TEACHES US
WHAT HAPPENS TO FAMILIES WHO
EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS IN THE
REAL WORLD WITHOUT ANY SPECIAL
INTERVENTION.
ON AVERAGE THESE FAMILIES SPENT
FOUR OF THE NEXT THIRTY SEVEN
MONTHS.
LIVING AND EMERGENCY SHELTER.
MOST DID RECEIVE SOME FORMS OF
SERVICES. 20% RECEIVED RAPID RE
HOUSING AND 30% TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING.
AND OVER ONE THIRD EVENTUALLY
GOT SOME FORM OF HOUSING
VOUCHERS.
DESPITE THIS AT THREE YEARS 39%
REPORTED HAVING BEEN DOUBLED UP
ARE HOMELESS IN THE PRIOR SIX
MONTHS. 18% REPORTED BEING
HOMELESS THREE YEARS AFTER THEIR
ADDITION AND NATIONAL EPISODE.
THE FAMILIES WHO RECEIVED
HOUSING CHOICE VOUCHERS
IMMEDIATELY AFTER RANDOMIZATION
DID THE BEST BY FAR.
THERE ARE HOUSING AND HEALTH
OUTCOMES WERE SIGNIFICANTLY
BETTER THAN THE OTHER GROUPS.
PEOPLE ASSIGNED TO THIS GROUP
THE VOUCHER GROUP WHERE ONE HALF
AS LIKELY TO HAVE ANY
HOMELESSNESS EXPERIENCES IN THE
NEXT THREE YEARS.
SOME OTHER NOTABLE FINDINGS
THOSE WHO RECEIVE VOUCHERS
COMPARED TO THOSE IN USUAL CARE
WHERE HALF IS LIKELY. TO
EXPERIENCE FAMILY VIOLENCE IN
THE NEXT THREE YEARS.
AND THE ADULTS WERE LESS LIKELY
TO HAVE SUBSTANCE USE PROBLEMS
OR PSYCHOLOGICAL DISTRESS
[inaudible]
CHILDREN EXPERIENCE FEWER SCHOOL
MOVES LESS ABSENCES.
AND FEWER BEHAVIORAL PROBLEMS.
IMPORTANTLY IN THE LONG TERM
FAMILIES ASSIGNED TO RAPID RE
HOUSING DID NOT FARE MUCH BETTER
THAN FAMILIES ASSIGNED TO USUAL
CARE.
THOSE IN RAPID RE HOUSING HAD A
SIMILAR LIKELIHOOD OF
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS AT THE
FILE WHAT POINTS AS THOSE WITH
USUAL CARE.
THOSE IN PROJECT BASED HOUSING
HAD BETTER OUTCOMES IN THE SHORT
TERM BUT NOT IN THE LONG TERM.
THEY DID NOT EXPERIENCE BETTER
WELL BEING THAN THOSE IN USUAL
CARE.
INTERESTINGLY THE TOTAL PROGRAM
COSTS OF THOSE WHO RECEIVE
VOUCHERS WAS ONLY FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS MORE OVER THE NEXT THREE
YEARS THEN THOSE ASSIGNED TO
USUAL CARE.
THIS IS IN PART BECAUSE DOES IN
USUAL CARE RECEIVED SOME OF THE
SERVICES FOR INSTANCE SUMMIT
COULD EVENTUALLY RECEIVE
VOUCHERS.
BUT IT'S ALSO BECAUSE SHELTER
AND TEMPORARY PROGRAMS ARE
EXPENSIVE.
EVEN IF THEY'RE NOT EFFECTIVE.
THERE'S MUCH MORE TO SAY ABOUT
THE STUDY AND I CERTAINLY
ENCOURAGE ENCOURAGE YOU TO READ
IT.
IT GIVES A SENSE OF BOTH THE
ENORMOUS TOLL OF HOMELESSNESS ON
FAMILIES AND PRESENTS A WAY
FORWARD.
IMPLEMENTING HOUSING VOUCHERS IS
NOT AN EASY SOLUTION.
CURRENTLY ONLY ONE IN FOUR
HOUSEHOLDS NATIONWIDE THAT IS
ELIGIBLE FOR VOUCHERS RECEIVE
SPAM.
AS YOU KNOW SECTION EIGHT
EXACTLY.
RAPIDLY AS YOU KNOW IN MANY OF
OUR COSTLIEST REGIONS IN
CALIFORNIA.
EVEN WITH A VOUCHER IT CAN BE
VERY DIFFICULT TO USE THAT.
RAPID RE HOUSING IS LIKELY A
READ REASONABLE OPTION TO
STABILIZE FAMILIESWHILE WE
AWAIT A MORE PERMANENT OPTION
BUT THE DATA IS PRETTY CLEAR
THAT IF WE COULD DO THE BEST
THING IT WOULD BE TO GET THOSE
FAMILIES VOUCHERS RIGHT AWAY.
IT MAKES CLEAR THAT THE SOLUTION
TO FAMILY HOMELESSNESS.
IS HOUSING.
WHEN WE TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THE
LIFELONG TOLL A FAMILY
HOMELESSNESS ON CHILDREN'S WELL
BEING?
AND THE CLEAR AN EVIDENT
SOLUTIONS TO COMMERCE MISS WE
ARE COMPELLED TO ACT.
AS A PHYSICIAN WHO CARES FOR LOW
INCOME ADULTS I FEAR THAT WE
WILL CONTINUE TO SEE THE
LIFELONG EFFECTS OF TOXIC STRESS
ON HOMELESSNESS.
FROM THESE CHILDREN WELL INTO
THEIR ADULTHOOD.
I CAN THINK OF NO BETTER
INVESTMENT IN THE FUTURE OF THIS
STATE THEN THE WELL BEING OF OUR
CHILDREN.
AND THE MEDICINE THAT ARCH STE
IS SAFE AFFORDABLE AND PERMANENT
HOUSING.
THANK YOU.
DOCTOR COASTAL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH -- THIS.
ONE QUICK QUESTION FROM SENATOR
SKINNER.
I'M DOCTOR CRUCIAL THANKS I'VE
HEARD YOU BEFORE COULD YOU JUST
GIVE US VERY BRIEFLY.
A SENSE OF HOW DRAMATIC THE
REDUCTION IN FEDERAL FUNDING IS
BàN YET FOR THIS TYPE OF
EMERGENCY RENTAL ASSISTANCE OR
OR EVEN ON GOING RENTAL
ASSISTANCE YEAH IT'S ESTIMATED
THAT YOU KNOW IN IN.
ABOUT NINETEEN EIGHTY FEDERAL
SUPPORT FOR HOUSING AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THROUGH
PUBLIC HOUSING AUTHORITIES OR
THROUGH I'M SECTION EIGHT
VOUCHERS WAS DRAMATICALLY CUT.
SOME ESTIMATE THAT WERE NOW IN
SORT OF REAL DOLLARS AND IT'S
ABOUT A QUARTER OR 30% OF WHAT
WE WERE IN REAL DOLLARS IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY AND THEN WE
WONDER WHY WE HAVE A
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS.
AND I THINK AS A PHYSICIAN A LOT
OF PEOPLE WANT TO TALK TO ME
ABOUT MENTAL HEALTH IS CAUSING
HOMELESSNESS OR SUBSTANCE USE.
AND I'M HERE TO SAY HOMELESSNESS
RESULTS FROM A LACK OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
AND IF YOU COUPLE THAT WITH ALL
REDUCTION OF THE STATE IN TERMS
OF OUR CAL WORKOUT RANTS WE IT'S
ALSO THE REDUCTION IN INCOME FOR
PEOPLE TO EVEN BE ABLE TO PAY
FOR HOUSING EXACTLY AND WHEN
THERE WAS THERE AND THE
REDUCTION IN IN TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHT AT I HAVE.
ANDTHAT SORT OF THE CALIFORNIA
THAT FROM THERE YEAH --
ONE OTHER.
AND OF COURSE THEN IF WE ADD. TO
THAT WERE WAY BEHIND IN TERMS OF
NUMBER OF UNITS PER CAPITA YEAH
THEN SCARCITY DRIVES UP PRICES
SAQLAIN PRICES YOU COUPLE THAT
WITH THE LACK OF ASSISTANCE THAT
MIGHT BE NEEDED.
THE WAY INCREASING PRICES AND
THEN WE SEE THIS RISE IN
HOMELESSNESS COULD YOU COMMENT
JUST BRIEFLY --
I HAVE BEEN INTERACTING WITH A
LOT OF BOTH THE PEOPLE WHO
FAMILIES WHO ARE HOMELESS IN MY
DISTRICT IN THERE AND SERVICE
PROVIDERS.
AND THEY'VE INDICATED THAT.
THEY OFTEN HAVE VERY EXTREME
DIFFICULTY IN TERMS OF SHELTERS
YEAH THAT AND I I'M BRINGING
THIS UP AND I WANT YOU TO COME
IT BECAUSE YOU KNOW WE HAVE SORT
OF BEEN PUSHING TOWARDS.
EXPANDING SHELTERS BUT WHAT THE
MAYOR YES BUT WHAT IT HERE.
ANYWAY --
BUT WHAT.
THE FEEDBACK I'M GETTING IS FOR
EXAMPLE MANY SHELTERS.
ARE -- SEX
SEGREGATED THE HOMELESS MOTHER.
HER SON IS TWELVE OR OLDER ALL
THE SAID IN HER SON CAN'T BE IN
SHELTERS SHE WANTS TO KEEP HER
FAMILY TOGETHER RIGHT SO SHE
STAYS IN THE CAR YEAH FOR SHE
ANY NUMBER OF APPS LIKE THAT IF
YOU COULD JUST.
WRAP INCIDENTLY I MEAN I THINK A
LOT OF HOMELESS FAMILIES
ACTUALLY DON'T SHOW UP IN THEIR
SYSTEM BECAUSE OUR SYSTEM WORKS
SO POORLY FOR RIGHT NOW.
AND SO THEY ARE HIT IN EITHER IN
CARS OR THEIR SORT OF QUADRUPLED
UP IN AN UNSAFE HOUSING
ENVIRONMENT BECAUSE OUR SYSTEM
IS REALLY NOT ORIENTED TOWARDS
THEM. ONE OF THE REASONS I SPENT
SOME TIME ON THE FAMILY OPTION
STUDY IS IT ACTUALLY POINTS OUT
THAT.
SHELTERS ARE PRETTY EXPENSIVE
AND I KNOW HOUSING IS REALLY
HARD TO BUILD BUT I THINK WE
NEED TO KEEP OUR EYES ON THAT AS
OUR GOAL FOR THE SOLUTION.
AS WELL AS LOOK AT EXIT THE
EXISTING HOUSING STOCK IN THAT
YOU TALKED ABOUT THE SECTION
EIGHT LOOKING THAT VOUCHER
PROGRAMS CENTER RUBIO.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THIS
INFORMATION IT'S NOT REALLY
HEARTBREAKING WHEN YOU SOME OF
THE STATISTICS --
YOU KNOW HAVING BEEN ONE OF
THESE OUT FAMILIES THAT CAN
AFFORD HOUSING AND LIVED IN A
SINGLE.
YOU KNOW --
A UNIT WITH TWO OTHER FAMILIES
GROWING UP YOU KNOW THE SIZE
VERY PERSONAL TO ME BUT SECONDLY
I THINK A LOT OF IT HAS TO DO
WITH DIGNITY AS WELL ON I WAS A
FORMER TEACHERS I EXPLAINED AND
I REMEMBER --
IT TOOK ME THREE WEEKS TO REAL
TO DO WITH THAT DIGNITY OF LIFE
I MEAN THEY FEEL SO --
IT'S DIFFICULT FOR THEM
SOMETIMES TO REACH OUT WHEN
THEY'VE HAD A STABLE ENVIRONMENT
AND ALL THIS SUNDAY HAVE TO
REACH OUT AND SAY I NEED HOUSING
AND AND SO YES WE DID HAVE A LOT
OF THE STUDENTS AND FAMILIES
LIVING IN CARS AND AND IT'S
REALLY HARD BECAUSE YOU.
KNOW I FIND --
ALSO IS A FORMER COUNCILMEMBER
WE USED TO OFFER VOUCHERS
SOMETIMES FOR TEMPORARY HOUSING
AND A LOT OF PEOPLE FELT LIKE IT
WAS UP.
ARE FALSE HOPE IN THAT YOU'D GET
ON VOUCHERS FOR TEMPORARY
HOUSING AND THEN THEY'RE BACK IN
THE STREET AND SO THAT THEY
DON'T WANT TO BOTHER GOING INTO
HOTELS AND WE WOULD PROVIDE.
BECAUSE IT WAS IN A SOLUTION SO
SO HOPEFULLY TO THIS DIALOGUE WE
WOULD FIGURE OUT A WAY TO FIND
PERMANENT HOUSING AND TO YOUR
RIGHT AND SOMETIMES A SHELTER
OPTION WAS NOT AN OPTION.
OUR FAMILY THAT FOUND THEMSELVES --
HOMELESS DID NOT WANT TO GO TO
THESE SHELTERS THAT IT'S AN
FOREIGN CONCEPT AND THEY'RE NOT
USED TO IT BUT THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THE WORK THAT YOU DO IN THE
RESEARCH THAT YOU DO.
IF YOU WERE TO SPANISH.
THE LETTER SEATED IBM ANY DOES
THAT THE LAST TIME YES BECAUSE
THEN I KEY IS MORE IMPORTANT ON
TICKET THING I'M ASSIST A COMBAT
SELFIE ON THIS THAT THEY MARKET
IT CAN ALL SEEM OCT OCTOBER MOST.
RCN THOUGH WE'RE NOT PERSONA QUE
THAT GIVE YOU KNOW THAT
ACCORDING TO OUR SOULS OUT THEM
IN YOU GET A VETO NOT COST A
COMBINED SO MEDIASCOPE CAN
OPINION WITH EMAIL.
SOMEONE THANK YOU BUT IF YOU
LOOK AT THE COMMERCE A FEW
MINUTES BUT I MEAN WHAT I LEFT
IT WITH YOU ON THAT THE LAST
TIME YES.
IF YOU MANY THOSE CUT OFF YES.
WHAT YOU SAID RIGHT AND THANK
YOU?
INDULGING ME ONE LAST TIME BUT
THE OTHER THING THAT AND DOCTOR
CRUCIAL IF YOU IF YOU CAN VERIFY
THIS OR NOT DOESN'T MATTER BUT
ONE THING I JUST WANTED.
TO BRING TO THE ATTENTION OF
THAT MANY OF US THINK THAT THIS
ONLY HAPPENS TO PEOPLE WHO ARE
WERE REALLY HARD AND THEY'RE
LIKE AND YOU KNOW THAT IS JUST
WRONG AND I I SAY IT AS SOMEONE
WHO.
HAD A BRIEF AND TEMPORARY BOUT
OF HOMELESSNESS AND MY DAUGHTER
AND I DID LIVE IN MY CAMPER VAN.
AND WE WERE I WAS IN A BETWEEN
JOBS IN A PERIOD WHERE I WAS
BETWEEN JOBS.
AND THE SHAME OF AND YOU KNOW
YOU DON'T HAVE THE FIRST AND
LAST SO YOU CAN'T GET INTO YOUR
NEXT RENTAL UNIT.
END.
I WAS FORTUNATE I HAD A FRIEND
BASE OF SAFETY NET THAT THEY
COULD GIVE ME.
MY DAUGHTER AND I LIVED WITH
THEM FOR SOME PERIOD OF TIME
TILL I COULD GET THAT FIRST AND
LAST AND THEN WE SECURED HOUSING
WE'VE NOT HAD THE PROBLEM SINCE.
BUT IT CAN HAPPEN TO ANYONE FOR
ANY NUMBER OF REASONS.
AND THEN OF COURSE IT SPIRALS.
IN ANYWAY AT ABSOLUTELY I MEAN
AND I THINK IN ARE REALLY
DISTORTED HOUSING ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW HAS ONLY
TWENTY TWO UNITS OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FOR FAMILIES FOR EVERY
HUNDRED FAMILIES.
MAKING --
LAST SPEND THIRTY PER COME AND
DEPENDING ON WHERE YOU LIVE 30%
OF AREA MEDIUM IN SAN FRANCISCO
IS ACTUALLY QUITE A HIGH SALARY.
AND IT'S LIKE THAT CHILDHOOD
GAME OF MUSICAL CHAIRS THERE
SIMPLY ENOUGH HOUSING AND IT
REALLY CAN AND DOES HAPPEN TO
ANYBODY THE SHAME ISRAEL THE
FEAR IS REAL BECAUSE PEOPLE'S
CHILDREN ARE TAKEN AWAY FROM
THEM.
IF THEY ARE HOMELESS AND SO
THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
FAMILIES DON'T WANNA PRESENT
BECAUSE THEY FEAR THAT THEIR
CHILDREN WILL BE REMOVED.
THE TRAUMA IS REAL AND IT REALLY
SPIRALS ON ITSELF BECAUSE WHEN
YOU DON'T HAVE HOUSING YOU KNOW
PEOPLE WIND UP LOSING THEIR JOB
OR THEIR KIDS YOU KNOW MIGHT NOT
WANT TO GO TO THE MOTEL BECAUSE
IT MIGHT MEAN A DIFFERENT SCHOOL
OR OR TWO YOU KNOW TRANSFERRING
SO.
IT'S A REALLY TERRIBLE PROBLEM
THAT WE NEED.
TO ADDRESS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I WANT
TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES --
FOR YOUR WILLINGNESS TO SHARE
YOUR PERSONAL STORIES BECAUSE I
THINK WE HAVE A COLLECTIVE
RESPONSIBILITY TO RE EDUCATE
MANY OF OUR COLLEAGUE SOMETIMES
ABOUT THE TRUE FACE AND CAUSES
OF HOMELESSNESS I APPRECIATE YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DOCTOR.
GOOD AFTERNOON PANEL TO COME FOR
THE NEXT PANEL THE FOCUS WILL BE
THE HOUSING LANDSCAPE FOR
CHILDREN YOUNG ADULTS AND
FAMILIES IN CALIFORNIA.
WE'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM SEAMUS
ROLLER MISTER ROLLER IS
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
NATIONAL HUSING LAW PROJECT
HE'S WORKED IN VARIOUS POSITIONS
RELATED TO HOUSING.
HE ALSO HAS HAD EXPERIENCE IN
RUNNING THE MEDITATION YOGA
PROGRAM FOR INCARCERATED YOU.
HE'LL BE JOINED BY ELDER TONY
MACNEIL SHE'S A MOTHER FOR
NATIVE OF STOCKTON AND AN
ORDAINED ELDER AT VICTORY PRAISE
CHURCH WHERE SHE IS DIRECTOR OF
THE SOCIAL JUSTICE MINISTRIES.
AS THEY'RE GETTING THE JUST THAT
I WANTED TO REMIND SENATOR
SKINNER ON ON ON A BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE ABOUT FOUR FIVE
YEARS AGO THERE WAS A MOTHER --
FROM SACRAMENTO WHO CAME AND
TOLD THAT STORY ABOUT NOT BEING
ABLE TO GO TO THE SHELTER
BECAUSE HER SON IT HIT.
FOURTEEN AND THAT SHELTERS
POLICY WAS AT FOURTEEN YOU GO TO
THE A SINGLE ADULT IDE OF THE
SHELTER AND HOW THAT WAS
UNTENABLE TO HER.
AS A MOTHER OF A SON MY SON WAS
FOUR TO YEAR AND I CAN ONLY
IMAGINE AND SO.
SHE COULD EXPLAIN TO MEMBERS OF
THE SUBCOMMITTEE WHO ASK WHY DO
YOU CHOOSE AIR QUALITY TO LIVE
ON THE RIVER IN YOUR CAR.
AND WHEN SHE WALKS THROUGH THE
POLICIES IN THE RULES AND
REGULATIONS THAT LIMITED HER
TRUE OPTIONS IT WAS A HOPEFULLY
I OPENING FOR EVERYONE ON THAT
PANEL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE BINS
JOINED BY SELECT COMMITTEE
MEMBER CENTER COPYRIGHT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING HERE.
THANK YOU GO AHEAD.
CHAIR MATCH ALL MEMBERS OF
SELECT COMMITTEE MY NAME SEAMUS
ROLLER IN THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE NATIONAL HOUSING LAW
PROJECT.
I WAS HERE IN SACRAMENTO THIS
WEEKEND MY PARENTS LIVE HERE AND
I WAS TALKING WITH MY MOM.
AND SHE REALLY SHE MOVED
FREQUENTLY AS A CHILD --
DUE TO MY GRANDMOTHERS ECONOMIC
CIRCUMSTANCES AND ALCOHOLISM --
THE THEY MOVE VERY OFTEN WHEN
SHE WAS VERY YOUNG IN.
WHEN SHE WAS SEVEN SEVENTH GRADE
SHE MOVED FROM MINNESOTA TO
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA?
AND SHE WAS GETTING AN AWARD IN
SEVENTH GRADE --
FOR FOR ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT AND
SHE ONLY HAD ABOUT TWO WEEKS
LEFT TO SECOND GRADE SEVENTH
GRADE AND SHE WAS BANGING HER
MOTHER -- TO
ALLOW HER TO STAY THOSE LAST TWO
WEEKS SO SHE CAN GET THE AWARD
WHICH WAS IMPORTANT TO OUR AND
FOR WHATEVER REASON MY
GRANDMOTHER REFUSED AND MOVE
THEM OUT TO CALIFORNIA --
TWO WEEKS BEFORE SEVENTH GRADE
WAS OVER.
MY MOM WAS TALKING ABOUT HOW
IMPACTFUL THAT WAS FOR HER AND
HOW PAINFUL IT WAS TO MOVE.
AND HOW EACH TIME SHE MOVED
THERE WERE PRIZED POSSESSIONS
LEFT BEHIND AND FRIENDS LEFT
BEHIND.
AND SOCIAL NETWORKS THAT RIGHT
THAT SHE WAS LEAVING BEHIND AS
WELL.
AND YOU KNOW THAT.
IN HERE IN CALIFORNIA I THINK
THAT YOU KNOW HOUSING STABILITY
IS JUST DOESN'T BOIL DOWN TO
COST ALONE THERE ARE MANY OTHER
FACTORS FOR FAMILIES.
THAT PLAY AND THAT OUR PERSONAL
AND ECONOMIC AND COMMUNITY.
BUT THE POINT I THINK WE'VE HAD
IN CALIFORNIA IS IS THAT THE THE
HOUSING COSTS ARE EATING UP
PEOPLE'S INCOME.
THAT THEY MAKE SMALL DECISIONS
OR SMALL STROKES OF BAD LUCK IN
THE CRISES IN A WAY THAT
WOULDN'T HAVE HAPPENED TWENTY
YEARS AGO IN CALIFORNIA.
AND PUSH FAMILIES INTO INTO
DIFFICULT CIRCUMSTANCES --
YOU KNOW I COULD SPEND THE
ENTIRE TIME KIND OF GOING
THROUGH STATISTICS --
ON KIND OF HOW BAD IT IS IN
CALIFORNIA BUT MY GUESS IS THAT
MOST OF YOU KNOW SORT OF HOW BAD
IT IS.
IN YOUR OWN COMMUNITIES YOU'VE
HEARD FROM OTHER PEOPLE.
A COUPLE OF JUST.
SMALL THINGS.
THERE ONE POINT SEVEN MILLION
HOUSEHOLDS IN CALIFORNIA THAT
PAY MORE THAN HALF OF THEIR
INCOME IN RENT.
YEAH THOSE ARE HOUSEHOLD STAFF
MORE THAN ONE PERSON AND A LOT
OF PEOPLE WHO ARE JUST.
YOU KNOW MAKING THOSE TOUGH
DECISIONS ABOUT WHAT THEY'RE
GOING TO PAY --
FOR TEN POINT 9% OF ALL CSU
STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA HAVE
EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS IN THE
LAST TWELVE MONTHS. TWENTY ONE
OF THE THIRTY MOST EXPENSIVE
RENTAL HOUSING MARKETS IN THE
ENTIRE COUNTRY ARE IN CALIFORNIA.
THIS IS JUST A FEW I THINK OF
THE DATA POINTS TO KIND OF
DESCRIBE THE SITUATION WE FIND
OURSELVES IN CALIFORNIA.
IN ITS INTERSECTION I THINK WITH
[inaudible]
WITH HELP.
HEALTHCARE IS A THREE POINT
THREE TRILLION DOLLAR BUSINESS.
IN THE UNITED STATES 90% OF
THOSE COSTS ARE RELATED TO
CHRONIC DISEASE AND MENTAL
HEALTH.
AND THOSE THINGS ARE CLOSELY
TIED TO SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF
HEALTH.
AND THAT CHRONIC DISEASE IS
DRIVEN.
IN A GREAT DEAL BY POVERTY
THAT'S FACED BY FAMILIES.
AND DRIVES UP OUR HEALTHCARE
COSTS -- BUT
ALSO THAT THE REASON THAT WE PAY
SO MUCH FOR HOUSING IS BECAUSE
WE REFUSE TO SEE HOUSING AND THE
OTHER SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF
HEALTH AS PART OF THE HEALTH
DELIVERY SYSTEM IN OUR COUNTRY.
AND WITHIN OUR STATE.
BUT IN ADDITION TO ALL THE
HEALTH COSTS THERE ALSO THE VERY
SIGNIFICANT COSTS ON OUR ECONOMY
A COSTS IN THE QUALITY OF LIFE.
AND JUST ON THE DESIRE OF PEOPLE
TO REMAIN IN OUR STATE ALL
TOGETHER.
SO TO TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
WHAT I SEE IS THE ORIGINS OF
PROBLEMS A HOUSING CRISIS IN
CALIFORNIA.
IN IT SO OFTEN WE TALK ABOUT THE
HOUSING MARKET BUT THAT THAT.
THE HOUSING MARKET IN
CALIFORNIA'S HIGHLY REGULATED
THE GOVERNMENT INTERVENES IN SO
MANY DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE
PROCESS IN THE DEVELOPMENT AND
AND AND HOW HOUSING IS REGULATED.
SO IT THE PROBLEM I WANT TO
BREAK IT DOWN INTO TWO BUCKETS
THAT WE HAVE BOTH THE LACK OF
HOUSING SUPPORTS THE LACK OF
FUNDING.
AND IT TOO WE HAVE PUBLIC
POLICIES AS A WHOLE THAT HAVE
MADE HOUSING MORE EXPENSIVE IN
CALIFORNIA.
IN A VERY BROAD LEVEL WE
DESIGNED A HOUSING SYSTEM THAT
MAXIMIZES BENEFITS FOR PEOPLE
WHO ALREADY OWN PROPERTY.
PEOPLE WITH WEALTH.
REALTORS AND REAL ESTATE
SPECULATORS.
I KNOW THIS MAY SOUND LIKE A
RADICAL STATEMENT IN SOME WAYS
BUT IT'S ACTUALLY JUST THE FACTS.
YOU CAN ARGUE ABOUT WHAT THE
VALUES ARE THOSE DECISIONS ARE
NOT BUT IN MANY WAYS AS A JUST
FACTS ABOUT HOW WE DESIGN A
HOUSING SYSTEM CALIFORNIA.
I DON'T THINK THOSE THAT WE
DECIDED THAT WE WANTED THAT
OUTCOME BUT A SERIES OF SMALL
DECISIONS PRODUCED THAT.
WE'VE SEEN HUGE CUTS.
IN FEDERAL AND STATE HOUSING
PROGRAMS.
WE SEE ON YEARS OF ZONING AND
OTHER LAND USE CAN STARK
CONTROLS.
THAT HAVE BEEN DESIGNED TO
REINFORCE SEGREGATE DOES A
CERTAIN WAY OF LIVING IN OUR
STATE --
THAT WE'VE DECIDED TO LET THE
DESIRES OF THE IMMEDIATE
NEIGHBORS OVERRULED THE NEEDS OF
THE REGION AND OF THE STATE.
THAT WE'VE IMPOSED A VERY
EXPENSIVE IDEA THAT THE ONLY
ACCEPTABLE WAY TO LIVE IS IN A
SINGLE FAMILY HOME IN THE
SUBDIVISION.
THAT WE'VE ZONED OUT MULTI
FAMILY HOUSING WITH NO NOT
RESIDENTIAL HOTELS ROOMING
HOUSES.
ANY OTHER WAYS THAT PEOPLE HAVE
HISTORICALLY KEPT THEMSELVES OUT
OF HOMELESSNESS WHEN THEY'RE ON
THE EDGE.
IT WILL DEVELOP THE TAX POLICY
LIKE PROPOSITION THIRTEEN THE
SKEW THE TAX MARKET THE PROVIDES
HUGE BENEFITS TO PEOPLE THAT
STAY IN THEIR HOMES FOR A LONG
TIME.
THE REDUCE IT PROPERTY TAX RATE
AND FORCES TO PUT IMPACT FEES ON
HOUSING THAT ARE TWO TO THREE
TIMES.
WHAT IT TAKES TO COVER THE COST
OF SERVICES MORTGAGE INTEREST
DEDUCTION THAT BENEFITS YOU THE
HIGHER YOUR TAX BRACKET IS --
AND PROPERTY OWNERSHIP RULES
ALLOW LOTS OF PEOPLE TO HOLD
HOUSING AND LLC'S AND HIDE THE
OWNERSHIP.
AND ALLOWED LOTS OF PEOPLE FROM
OTHER COUNTRIES TO LAUNDER THEIR
MONEY HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
SO AS WE THINK ABOUT SOLVING THE
HOUSING CRISIS IN CALIFORNIA I
THINK THEREFORE BUCKETS THAT I
THINK ABOUT. ONE WE NEED TO
INVEST IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND HOUSING
SUPPORTS OVERALL.
WE NEED TO ALTER THE TAX SYSTEM
IN A WAY THAT.
MAKES AN EQUAL PLAYING FIELD.
FOR RENTERS AND FOR PEOPLE
TRYING TO BUY HOMES.
THAT WE NEED TO CREATE AN
CENTRAL CREATE INCENTIVES FOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO GREEN LIGHT
MORE HOUSING PRODUCTION AND TO
PUNISH EXCLUSIONARY ZONING.
MUCH OF SILICON VALLEY FOR
INSTANCE IS STILL DEVELOP LIKE
IT'S A SUBURB OF OMAHA AND NOT
LIKE IT'S A ONE OF THE BIGGEST
JOB CENTERS.
IN THE COUNTRY.
I THINK THE GOVERNOR'S IDEA OF
LOOKING HOUSING ELEMENT REFORM
IS GREAT.
BUT I THINK THAT ANY SOLUTION WE
LOOK AT MUST REALLY TACKLE
EXCLUSIONARY ZONING.
AND IT CAN'T JUST BE FOCUSED ON
OBSERVING BLACK AND BROWN
NEIGHBORHOODS.
AROUND THE STATE.
AND LASTLY THAT WE NEED TO
PROTECT THE RIGHTS OF TENANTS.
AT THE VERY LEAST YOU SHOULDN'T
BE AFFECTED IF YOU'RE PLAYING BY
THE RULES AND PAYING YOUR RENT.
AND THAT WE SHOULDN'T LET THE
GROWTH OF CORPORATE LANDLORDS
LIKE BLACKSTONE.
FIND WAYS TO MONETIZE EVICTING.
OUR RENTERS IN OUR STATE THAT WE
NEED TO ENFORCE THE FAIR HOUSING
LAWS THAT WE HAVE IN STRENGTH IN
THOSE.
IN SORT OF MY ADD ON TO THAT IS
THAT THERE ARE THREE BIG SYSTEMS
THAT INFLUENCE HOMELESSNESS IN
CALIFORNIA THAT ARE CONTROLLED
BY THE STATE.
HEALTH CARE CHILD WELFARE AND
CORRECTIONS AND THERE'S A LOT OF
WORK TO BE DONE IN EACH OF THOSE
SYSTEMS. TO LOWER THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE THAT ARE ENTERING INTO
HOMELESSNESS.
THERE ARE A WHOLE RANGE OF WAYS
Y. IN WHICH YOU ALL AS A STATE
GOVERNMENT CAN SHIFT THE NATURE
OF THE HOUSING SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA.
BUT I THINK THE FIRST QUESTION
IS ONE OF VALUES AND PRIORITIES
WHAT THE OUTCOMES DO YOU WANT TO
SEE.
IS IT MORE IMPORTANT HOUSING
REMAINS AN IN OR IS IT MORE
IMPORTANT THAT OUR HOUSING
POLICY WORKS TO PROVIDE STABLE
HOUSING FOR THE MOST NUMBER OF
FAMILIES.
POSSIBLE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND I'M GONNA --
BE SURE TO ASK THAT ALL THE
WITNESSES PROVIDE.
OF MY STAFF WITH COPIES OF YOUR
WRITTEN TESTIMONY --
YOU COULD EMAIL LATER --
SO THAT IT CAN BE ADDED TO THE
WEBSITE FOR THE SELECT COMMITTEE
PLEASE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
YOU'RE WELCOME.
HELLO OKAY YOU CAN HEAR ME.
I'M SO MY NAME IS TONY MACNEIL --
I AM AN ELDER VICTORY AND PRAISE
CHURCH I AM A NATIVE OF STOCKTON
CALIFORNIA --
I AM A COMMUNITY ORGANIZER WITH
FAITH IN THE VALLEY.
AND I AM GOING TO SHARE WITH YOU
MY STORY --
SURROUNDING HOUSING --
AND I WANNA MAKE SURE.
THAT AS I SHARE MY STORY SAID
THE STORE THAT I SHARE THAT YOU
ALL ARE VERY CLEAR THAT I AM
SITTING IN THIS SEAT.
REPRESENTING.
SO MANY WOMEN --
AND SO ACCOUNTED A PRIVILEGE AND
AN HONOR --
AND I'M I'M EXTREMELY GRATEFUL
TO BE ABLE TO BE IN THE SPACE --
IN ORDER TO SHARE THIS STORY
BECAUSE IT LETS ME KNOW THAT
EVERYTHING THAT I'VE GONE
THROUGH.
WASN'T IN VAIN --
THAT THERE WAS A PURPOSE AND A
REASON AND I DIDN'T REALIZE IT
UNTIL I WAS PREPARING TO COME
HERE TODAY.
MY FIRST TOUCH WITH HOMELESSNESS
WAS DUE TO DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
I WAS IN AND OUT OF DIFFERENT
SHELTERS FOR APPROXIMATELY A
YEAR -- I
WENT INTO A PROTECTIVE SHELTER
WITH MY FOUR CHILDREN.
AND WEEK HELP SERVED --
A FEW MONTHS AFTER THAT I HAD TO
SPLIT MY CHILDREN UP IN ORDER.
FOR MYSELF TO BE SAFE AND IN
ORDER TO CONTINUE TO KEEP US.
IN A SPACE --
WHERE WE WILL COVER I TO
RELOCATE OUT OF TOWN FOR A FEW
MONTHS JUST TO REGROUP --
WHICH WAS DEVASTATING AND
TRAUMATIZING TO MY CHILDREN --
ONE OF MY DAUGHTERS ACTUALLY
STOP SPEAKING ALTOGETHER TO
ANYONE -- WE
CAME BACK TOGETHER THE ENDER IN
THE LATTER PART OF THE YEAR --
I LEFT ABOUT A JANUARY ISSUE AND
WE CAME BACK TOGETHER --
AROUND THANKSGIVING --
WE SPENT THANKSGIVING IN A WOMEN
AND CHILDREN SHELTER --
A DORMITORY --
HE WAS FOR THE FOR BABIES AND SO
I'D HAVE TO WITH MY FEET.
AND I HAD MY BABY --
WHO WAS NOT ONE YET AND TOOK HIS
FIRST STEPS AT THE SELTER
ACTUALLY --
ON MY CHEST AND MY TWO YEAR OLD
LANE ON THE SIDE OF ME I GOT
PERMISSION FROM THEM TO SHARE
THIS.
WITH YOU ALL THEY HAD NO IDEA
THAT THINGS WERE AS BAD AS THEY
WERE THAT MOM HAD PNEUMONIA AND
WAS WORKING TWO JOBS AND
CATCHING THE BUS IN DOING
EVERYTHING THAT SHE COULD JUST
TO SAVE UP MONEY. TO GET INTO A
PLACE ANYWAY DID GET IN --
AND WAS THERE --
FOR ABOUT SEVEN YEARS BUT THE
CHILDREN HAD TO BE MOVED BECAUSE
THE PLACE IS A HOT SPOT.
I'M IN THE CITY OF STOCKTON AND
HAVE BEEN CONSISTENTLY A HOT
SPOT.
FROM THERE SO I STARTED LOOKING
FOR A BETTER PLACE FOR US TO
LEAH -- IT
ALSO MEANT STAYING IN THAT PLACE
I HAD TO WORK --
A LOT OF HOURS IN ORDER TO MAKE
SURE THAT I COULD CONTINUE TO
PAY THE RENT.
SO THAT WE DIDN'T EVER HAVE TO
EXPERIENCE BEING HOMELESS AGAIN --
MY SECOND TOUCH WITH
HOMELESSNESS --
WAS THE TWENTY FICTION --
NOW WE'VE MOVED JUST SO THAT YOU
KNOW --
WITHIN A PERIOD OF TWENTY FIVE
YEARS -- Là
AB MOVES SIXTEEN TIMES.
I'VE BEEN EVICTED ONE TIME NONE
OF THOSE TIMES HAD TO DO WITH ME
NOT PAYING MY RENT.
JUST I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT NARRATIVE.
IS CANCELED.
I'VE WORKED ALWAYS I'VE BEEN
MANAGER SUPERVISOR LEADER MENTAL
WAR I'VE WORKED TWO JOBS THREE
JOBS IF NECESSARY --
I'VE DONE EVERYTHING WAY OFF
WELFARE I WORKED MY WAY ALSO
SECTION EIGHT I WORKED MY WAY
OFF OF EVERY GOVERNMENT
ASSISTANCE THAT THERE WAS --
IN ORDER TO MAKE SURE THAT I
TOOK CARE OF MY FAMILY --
SOUL WHEN WE WERE EVICTED THE
OWNER DECIDED SHE DID NOT WANT.
TO RENT ANYMORE THAT SHE WANTED
TO SELL THE HOUSE --
AND SHE MADE THAT DECISION AFTER
ACCEPTING OUR SIX SECTION EIGHT
APPLICATION AND AFTER ACCEPTING
MY CATS --
FUN BUT NOT HAVING RECEIVED THE
PART FROM SECTION EIGHT AND SO
SHE USE THAT AS LEVERAGE TO BE
ABLE TO WE VICTOR US --
AND I COULD ARGUE IT AND MY
WORKER COULDN'T SEEM TO WORK
WITH HER AND FAIR HOUSING
COULDN'T GET HER TO CHANGE HER
MIND AND SO ONCE AGAIN WE WERE
HOMELESS --
WE WORK OUT SURFING A LITTLE BIT
STAYING WITH FRIENDS FROM CHURCH --
FINALLY FOUND A PRIVATE OWNER
THAT WAS WILLING. TO ACCEPT
SECTION.
EIGHT THE THIRD TIME THAT WE
WERE DISPLACED ON THE HOME OWNER
DECIDED THAT SHE WAS GOING TO
ACCEPT THE MY RENT.
AND MY SECTION EIGHT VOUCHER AND
THE PORTION THAT SECTION EIGHT
PAID HER BUT NOT PAY THE
MORTGAGE.
WHEN I CAME HOME ONE DAY FROM
CHURCH I'M TRYING TO TO BE
EMOTIONAL?
THERE WAS A NOTICE ON THE DOOR
LETTING US KNOW THAT WE HAD TO
VACATE --
AND WE COULD NO LONGER STAY IN
THIS PLACE THANKFULLY ONE OF THE
LADIES AT THE CHURCH ALLOWED US
TO RESIDE WITH HER I HAD NO
WHERE TO TAKE OUR I DIDN'T HAVE
THE FUNDS. TO PUT THINGS IN
STORIES --
AND I HAD TO HURRY AND MOVE SO I
HAD JUST A SHORT AMOUNT OF TIME
WE IN SHORT LOST EVERYTHING TO
SQUATTERS WHILE WE STAYED.
IN THE HOUSE TEMPORARILY AND
FINALLY FOUND ANOTHER PLACE TO
LIVE -- I'VE
USED -- I'VE
USED THE LIFETIME ASSISTANCE
WITH TENNIS ONCE I'VE RECEIVED
CENTRAL VALLEY HOUSING
ASSISTANCE ONCE I RECEIVE CHURCH
ASSISTANCE ONCE --
I'VE ALWAYS BEEN EMPLOYED LIKE I
STATED OF SCHOOL TIME --
AND IN ORDER TO PUT I CELLS FROM.
BEING HOMELESS AGAIN AND PAIN
OVER 80% OF MY INCOME NOW I RENT
A ROOM.
MY CHILDREN ARE ADULTS MY THIRTY
YEAR OLD DAUGHTER AND GRANDSON
LIVE IN A TINY BOX THEY ARE
BARELY MAKING IT SHE PAYS 85% OF
HER INCOME SHE'S TRYING TO FIND
A SECOND JOB.
IF SHE WORKS AS AN ASSISTANT AT
A SCHOOL DISTRICT AND SHE DOES
UBER DRIVING ON THE SIDE AND
SHE'S ALSO TRYING TO MAKE SURE
THAT MY GRANDSON ISN'T A
STATISTIC BECAUSE THEY DO MAKE
BEDS FOR THIRD GRADERS FOR
PRISON.
SO SHE'S TRIED TO ENSURE THAT
SHE'S GREAT IN PARENTING AND
THAT HE DOESN'T LOSE HOUSING AND
THAT SHE ENDS UP HOMELESS MITES
TWENTY SIX YEAR OLD DAUGHTER DID
GET EVICTED WITHOUT BECAUSE
BECAUSE THE DOG GOT OUT SO THAT
THEY COULD ELEVATE HER RED.
WHICH WAS IN ANOTHER HOT ZONE IN
STOCKTON --
ONCE SHE GOT EVICTED SHE ENDED
UP STAYING WITH SOMEONE THAT WAS
NOT SAFE SHE HAD TO SPLIT HER
FOR HER THREE CHILDREN UP IN
ORDER TO STAY WHERE SHE WS
FINALLY LANDED.
IN A STUDIO APARTMENT THAT SHE
COULD AFFORD SHE WORKED FOR TEST
Là SHE WAS MAKING MONEY BUT
COULD NOT AFFORD THREE TIMES THE
AMOUNT OF WARRANT IN ORDER TO
STAY -- MY
DAUGHTERS I'VE HAD FIVE
DIFFERENT SCHOOLS THAT THEY
RESULT AND WENT TO WE MOVED SO
MUCH THEY WERE IN FIVE DIFFERENT
SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
EVERY SCHOOL DISTRICT HAS A
DIFFERENT LEARNING CURVE BUT
DIFFERENT ACADEMIC STRATEGY AND
SO THEY WOULD HAVE TO TRY TO
REGROUP RE ASSESS BUT BECAUSE I
HAD TO WORK SO MUCH TO KEEP THE
ROOF OVER OUR HEAD.
I COULD NOT ASSIST THEM IN
HELPING WITH THOSE THINGS THEY
NEVER GOT COUNSELING FOR THE
TRAUMA WE EXPERIENCE WITH
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE BECAUSE WE
NEVER HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
STILL AND SETTLED LONG ENOUGH.
IN ORDER TO ACTUALLY TAKE A DEEP
BREATH AND EXHALE MY ADULT
CHILDREN ARE NOW TRYING TO DEAL
WITH THE TRAUMA.
THAT WE HAVE HAD OVER ALL OF THE
YEARS.
OF BEING UNSTABLE AND I'M SURE.
THAT THIS WAS NOT [inaudible]
MY FAULT.
AND THAT I DIDN'T DO ANYTHING.
TO QUALIFY FOR BEING IN THE POOL
OF INSTABILITY.
OTHER THAN NOT MAKE ENOUGH MONEY
[inaudible]
MUST WORK.
AND I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
HAVING THE COURAGE TO SHARE WITH
ME.
QUESTIONS ON FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS CENTER CABALLERO
[inaudible]
HEARING THE JOHN [inaudible]
NEAR [inaudible]
YEAH.
I OUT LOUD ABOUT.
YEAH GETTING YOUR TESTIMONY HERE
TODAY -- ARE
YOU HAPPY IF YOU HAVE AN
INCREDIBLE JOB.
YOU HAVE THE OTHER --
EDUCATION.
YEAH ON THE SO I WANTED VERY
FINE THANK YOU VERY VERY MUCH.
OFF YEAH SOME OF THE SOME OF THE
IF I COULD GO BACK.
AND FIRE ON HAVE --
YEAH -- GET
THE ROLE.
COMMENTED I WAS WONDERING IF YOU
CAN GIVE US SOME IDEAS --
REALLY KNOW TODAY.
I'M LOOKING FOR YEAH WE HAD A WE
HAD A QUESTION REGARDING THE
ISSUE ABOUT.
I DIDN'T REALLY LIKE FROM YOUR
JACKSON MISSION --
DEFINITELY FEARFUL FOR LEGAL
HOUSES OR I THINK THAT ACTUALLY.
HOOVER BY.
DO YOU WANT TO LIVE [inaudible]
YEAH COURSE.
YOU KNOW I MEAN.
DURING THE START OF EXPLICIT
RACIAL IMPLICATIONS RIGHT FROM
THE VERY BEGINNING IN ABOUT
NINETEEN AT EIGHT IN YOU KNOW
ONCE THAT WAS MADE ILLEGAL A LOT
OF THAT SORT OF OTHER THINGS
THAT WERE IS ZONING WERE THERE
TO REPLACE THAT RIGHT SO THE
PROHIBITION ON THE BUILDING OF
APARTMENTS. FOR INSTANCE --
YOU KNOW THINGS IN PARTICULAR
STILL PLAYS OUT IN CALIFORNIA
WHERE YOU HAVE LOTS OF
pDIFFICULT TO BUILD ANY MULTI
FAMILY HOUSING.
OR EVEN LIKE TO BUILD A DUPLEX
FOR INSTANCE RIGHT THIS DESIGN
IN A PARTICULAR WAY TO MAKE THAT
COMMUNITY REMAIN VERY VERY
EXPENSIVE ARE LONG ERM.
SO I THINK THAT'S YOU KNOW ONE
OF THE PRIMARY THINGS THAT YOU
THINK ABOUT THAT ALSO.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE CITY OF SAN
FRANCISCO FOR INSTANCE.
YOU KNOW IN THE NINETEEN
THIRTIES THERE WERE NINETY
THOUSAND ROOMING HOUSES AND
SINGLE OCCUPANCY RESIDENCES ARE
ARE YOU KNOW OF A RESIDENTIAL
HOTELS.
ABOUT MAYBE YOU KNOW TWENTY
THOUSAND BY CHANGING SORT OF
WHAT WE THOUGHT WAS AN
APPROPRIATE WAY TO LIVE IN SOME
OF THE THINGS WE'RE GOOD LIKE
SOME OF THOSE.
RESIDENT SO HOTELS WERE NOT THE
BEST PLACES TO LIVE BUT SOME OF
THEM WERE JUST FINE IN THE WAYS
THAT FAMILIES FOUND A WAY TO
KIND OF MAKE ENDS MEET.
AND I THINK AS WE START TO LOOK
IT.
FIXING OUR HOUSING CRISIS WE'VE
GOT TO FIND.
YOU KNOW WAYS THEY BOTH INVOLVE
STATE SUBSIDY BUT ALSO WAYS THAT
INVOLVED YOU KNOW SORT OF
INNOVATION AND SORT OF RETURNING
TO SOME OF THE WAYS THAT WE HAS
PEOPLE IN THE PAST [inaudible]
HELLO.
WELL FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU FOR
SHARING YOUR STORY AND I WILL
ALSO SAY THE SAME THING.
OF COURSE IT'S NOT YOUR FAULT --
BUT THANK YOU FOR HAVING THE
COURAGE TO SHARE --
AND I HEARD A LOT OF THINGS THAT
RESONATE WITH ME IN PARTICULAR --
ONE AS AN EDUCATOR FOR MANY
YEARS AND NOW WILL START BY
SAYING THIS --
I WORK WITH A LOT OF THOUGHT
WONDERFUL TEACHERS BUT SOMETIMES
THERE IS A LACK OF UNDERSTANDING.
AND I WOULD OFTEN HEAR.
THE CALL CARE ABOUT THEIR
CHILDREN.
WHY DON'T THEY COME TO PARENT
TEACHER CONFERENCE WHY DON'T
THEY SHOW UP IN AND I TRIED SO
HARD TO EDUCATE THEM ON COMING
FROM UP IN A HOUSEHOLD WHERE?
MY YOU KNOW MY PARENTS WORKED
ALL THE TIME COULD IN A TEMPER
TEACHER CONFERENCE IT'S AN
EDUCATION PIECE THAT'S MISSING
TRYING TO GET THEM TO UNDERSTAND
THAT SOME PARENTS LIKE YOURSELF.
ARE HAVING A REALLY HARD TIME
JUST MAKING ENDS MEET AND SO YOU
KNOW WHAT YOU LET YOUR HOUSE
WILL FALL APART TO ATTEND A
PARENT TEACHER CONFERENCE.
IN FACT I'VE OFTEN PROPOSED YOU
KNOW THIS AND ALLOWING PARENTS
NOW THAT WE HAVE --
IPHONES YOU KNOW WHAT TO DO --
FACE TME FOR PARENT TEACHER
CONFERENCES BECAUSE YOU KNOW
IT'S IT'S REALLY DIFFICULT AGAIN
GREAT PEOPLE BUT SOMETIMES IS
THAT LACK OF UNDERSTANDING SO SO
THANK YOU FOR A FOUR EAST%
WORKING AND TRYING TO GET YOUR
FAMILY OUT OF YOUR SITUATION.
AND DOES SECOND HE OF COURSE MY
KIDS AS WELL PUBLICIZED I'M ALSO
A VICTIM OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AND AND ALSO THE LACK OF
UNDERSTANDING THAT SOMETIMES
EVEN WITH COUNSELING YOU KNOW
THE TRAUMA THAT VICTIMS
EXPERIENCE.
EMAIL --
RESURFACES IN IT IT'S JUST YEARS
BEFORE YOU CAN ACTUALLY PUT THAT
BEHIND YOU STILL THINK YOU FOR
SURVIVING THAT THANK YOU FOR
WORKING OUT FOR YOUR CHILDREN
AND AND YES AND THERE'S A LOT OF
THE MISCONCEPTION ABOUT YOU KNOW
FAMILIES LIKE YOURSELF IN OFF
INTO YOUR STIGMATIZE AND WILL.
MAKE THE ASSUMPTION YOU DON'T
CARE BUT TO YOU KNOW YOU DO
KERRY WAS IN YOUR FAULT AND AND
AGAIN IT TAKES YOUR STORIES. TO
TO REALLY BRING LIGHT SHED LIGHT
INTO WHAT HAPPENED SAW ONE
PARTICULAR INCIDENT.
IN YOUR CASE JUST IT WAS A
SPIRAL FACT TO CATCH UP SO FIRST
WHAT THINK YOU AND EMILY.
YOU KNOW I'M PROUD OF YOU THEY
ARE HERE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH COLLEAGUES
YOU KNOW THE THE THE CONCEPT OF
NAMIBIA'S THEM.
THERE'S BEEN TALK ABOUT
EXCLUSIONARY ZONING AND AND AS A
LIKE THAT OFFICIALS --
YOU KNOW WE HEAR FROM
CONSTITUENTS ALL THE TIME IT'S A
REAL.
WE HEAR FROM THOSE WHO NEED
HOUSING AND WE HEAR VERY LOUDLY
FROM THOSE WHO HAVE IT.
AND HAVE NO INTENTION. FOR THEIR
BLOCK TO LOOK ANY DIFFERENT.
I REPRESENT MID CITY LOS ANGELES
CULVER CITY AND WE HAVE A
COLLEAGUE WHO INTRODUCED.
A BILL LAST YEAR THAT IT NINE
YEARS IN THE LEGISLATURE I'VE
NEVER HAD.
THE SAME PERSPECTIVE ON A BAIL
FROM SOUTH LA. TWO CHEVY IDEALS.
AND THE THE CONCEPT WAS.
DON'T CHANGE THE CHARM OF MY
LOVELY CALIFORNIA COTTAGE MY
SINGLE FAMILY HOME.
OTHER THING THAT'S INTERESTING
I'M A DUPLEX OWNER --
AND THE NEIGHBORHOOD IN WHICH I
LIVE AND HAVE LIVED. FOR
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN YEARS NOW LOS
ANGELES IS PRIMARILY DUPLEXES.
BUILT IN THE TWENTIES.
BUT THE DESIGN WAS SUCH THAT
FROM THE STREET YOU COULD ONLY
SEE ONE FRONT DOOR THAT WAS A
PART OF THE DESIGN SO IT
WOULDN'T UP HERE.
LIKE A MULTI FAMILY HOME SO WE
HAVE A LOT OF I THINK SOUL
SEARCHING TO DO.
AS CALIFORNIA'S IN TERMS OF WHAT
KIND OF CALIFORNIA.
ALL WE WANT TO RAISE OUR
CHILDREN IN IN GROW OLD IN AND
AND WHAT IT WILL LOOK LIKE. FOR
ALL OF US WE WANT TO THANK YOU
BOTH FOR COMING.
APPRECIATE YOU AND THE YOUR
TESTIMONY ON THE WEBSITE.
AND WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO OUR
THIRD AND FINAL PANEL WHICH IS
THE SOLUTIONS PANEL HOUSING
SOLUTIONS TO STABILIZE FAMILIES.
AND IMPROVE HEALTH.
WE'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM WILLIAM
LATE WILLIAM LEHMAN.
YOUTH COORDINATED ENTRY SYSTEMS
MANAGER FOR THE LOS ANGELES
HOMELESS SERVICES AUTHORITY
[inaudible]
LHASA.
LHASA JUST INTO IT BELIEVES THAT
AMAZING REPORT LAST WEEK ON THE
ROLE OF RACE IN TERMS OF HOUSE
HOMELESSNESS IT.
TOOK MY BREATH AWAY.
SECOND WE'RE HERE OFF WILL HEAR
FROM ALEXANDER SASHA HARNDEN
POLICY ADVOCATE FROM.
MY OLD NECK OF THE WOODS WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY.
AND LASTLY AND HAULING FINANCING
YOUR FISCAL POLICY ANALYST WITH
THE LEDGE ANALYST'S OFFICE THE
LA YOU KNOW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING
HERE.
A GOOD AFTERNOON --
SENATOR MITCHELL AND MEMBERS OF
THE SELECT COMMITTEE THANKS SO
MUCH FOR INVITING ME TO SPEAK --
MY NAME IS WILL A MAN I AM THE
YOUTH COORDINATED ENTRY SYSTEM
MANAGER AT THE LOS ANGELES
HOMELESS SERVICES AUTHORITY
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS LHASA.
AND LHASA IS A JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITY THE CITY AND COUNTY OF
LOS ANGELES --
AND IS THE LEAD AGENCY FOR THE
LA CONTINUUM OF CARE.
AT LOS ALSO LEAD THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
COORDINATED ENTRY SYSTEM --
OR SEE ASSN LOS ANGELES COUNTY
THIS IS A COUNTY WIDE SYSTEM
THAT STREAMLINES ACCESS TO
HOUSING AND SERVICES FOR
FAMILIES ADULT AND YOUTH
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS.
AT MY TESTIMONY THIS AFTERNOON
WILL FOCUS SPECIFICALLY ON THE
NEEDS OF YOUTH AND YOUNG ADULTS
THAT IS --
INDIVIDUALS AGE.
SIXTEEN TO TWENTY AND HOUSEHOLDS
HEADED BY PERSONS IN THIS AGE
GROUP.
AS WELL AS RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
ENSURING THAT EXPERIENCES OF
HOMELESSNESS FOR THIS POPULATION
BECOME INCREASINGLY RARE BRIEF
AND NON RECURRING OR ONE TIME.
AT SENATORS MITCHELL RUBY IN
PARTICULAR IS YOU KNOW AND LA
COUNTY.
THE VOLUME OF NEED AMONG YOUTH
AND YOUNG ADULTS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS.
IS SIGNIFICANT.
ACCORDING TO LOSSES TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN YOUTH COUNT AN
ESTIMATED THIRTY THREE HUNDRED
YOUTH AND YOUNG ADULTS
EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS ON ANY
GIVEN NIGHT.
THIS INCLUDES MEMBERS OF YOUNG
FAMILIES AS WELL.
NEARLY HALF 4407% OF THESE YOUNG
PEOPLE ARE SLEEPING IN PLACES
NOT MEANT FOR HUMAN HABITATION
THAT INCLUDES THE STREETS.
ENCAMPMENTS OR IN THEIR VEHICLES.
OTHERS ARE STAYING IN SHELTER
OTHER IN TERM HOUSING OR
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING PROGRAMS.
BUT STATEWIDE FIFTEEN THOUSAND
YOUTH EXPERIENCE LITERAL
HOMELESSNESS ON ANY GIVEN NIGHT.
AND MORE THAN 20% RESIDE IN LA
COUNTY. TWO MORE SYSTEMATICALLY
ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF VALLEY'S
YOUTH LHASA ALONG WITH CITY AND
COUNTY PARTNERS AND YOU SERVICE
PROVIDERS.
IMPLEMENTED THE USE COORDINATED
ENTRY SYSTEM IN.
TWENTY SIXTEEN YOUTH THE S. IS
AT LEAST COUNTY WIDE SYSTEM FOR
IDENTIFYING ENGAGING AND
ADDRESSING THE HOUSING NEEDS OF
THE SPECIFIC POPULATION USING
YOUNG ADULTS.
THE SYSTEM CONNECTS PARTICIPANTS
TO SUPPORTIVE SERVICES AND A
MENU OF HOUSING RESOURCES BASED
ON THE PARTICIPANTS NEEDS.
AND PREFERENCES.
INCLUDING TRANSITIONAL HOUSING
RAPIDLY HOUSING NINE TIME
LIMITED SUPPORTIVE HOUSING AND
OTHER PERMANENT HOUSING SUCH AS
HOUSING CHOICE VOUCHERS.
THANKS LARGELY TO A SIGNIFICANT
INFLUX IN LOCAL RESORCES FOR
MEASURE H. A COUNTY SALES TAX
PASSED IN MARCH TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN PRODUCING THREE INNER
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY
FOR HOMELESS SERVICES.
THROUGH.
TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN LOS HAS
SIGNIFICANTLY EXPANDED TE
AVAILABILITY OF HOUSING
RESOURCES SPECIFICALLY FOR THE
YOUTH POPULATION OF THE LAST TWO
YEARS.
THIS INCLUDES THE ADDITION OF
FOUR HUNDRED INTERMENT
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING BATS FOR
YOUTH.
MORE THAN THREE HUNDRED RAPIDLY
HOUSING SLOTS.
SIGNIFICANT NEW PROJECT ANTENNA
BASED PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING.
AND NEW HOUSING FOCUS SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES --
INCLUDING SUPPORT FOR
RECONNECTING AND REUNIFYING WITH
FAMILY FOR YOUNG PEOPLE JUNCTION
WITH THESE EXPANSIONS WE'VE SEEN
THAT YOUNG PEOPLE HAVE FOUND
HIGH RATES OF SUCCESS IN CERTAIN
INTERVENTIONS.
NEARLY 80% OF YOUTH RAPIDLY
HOUSING PARTICIPANTS FOR EXAMPLE
OF EXITED TO PERMANENT HOUSING
SINCE THE INTERVENTION WAS
SCALED COUNTY WIDE IN.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN WHILE THE
EXPANSION TO HOUSING AND
SERVICES FOR YOUTH AND AND
RELATIVE SUCCESS OF THESE
HOUSING INTERVENTIONS ARE
SIGNIFICANT.
THE VOLUME OF NEED AMONG YOUNG
PEOPLE IN LA COUNTY AND
STATEWIDE CONTINUES TO FAR
EXCEED THE SUPPLY RESOURCES.
YOU SEE S. SERVED APPROXIMATELY
FOUR THOUSAND ON DUPLICATED
YOUTH AND YOUNG ADULTS IN
CALENDAR YEAR.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND WHILE THE
SYSTEM SUPPORTED APPROXIMATELY
ONE THOUSAND OF THOSE YOUNG
PEOPLE TO MOVE INTO PERMANENT
HOUSING NO SMALL FEAT.
THOUSANDS OF OTHER PARTICIPANTS
COULD NOT ACCESS PERMANENT
HOUSING DUE TO THE INSUFFICIENT
SUPPLY RESOURCES.
WE MUST ENSURE ALL YOUNG PEOPLE
CAN ACCESS SAFE AND STABLE
HOUSING.
AND THIS REQUIRES INCREASED
INVESTMENTS IN BOTH INNER MAN
PERMANENT HOUSING AS WELL AS
HOUSING RELATED SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES.
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE OH SEVEN
WHICH PROVIDES A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS AND ON GOING GRANT
FUNDING TO LOCAL CEO SEES.
AND YOU SERVICE PROVIDERS MAKE
SUCH AN INVESTMENT IN ADDRESSING
THE NEEDS OF YOUNG PEOPLE.
SB.
FIVE SIXTY EIGHT AUTHORED BY
SENATOR PILOT PORTANTINO WHICH
IS THAT WHICH IS A RAPIDLY
HOUSING PROGRAM FOR COLLEGE
STUDENTS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS AND HOUSING
INSTABILITY.
WOULD ALSO MAKE SUCH AN
INVESTMENT AND WITH THAT
SUBPOPULATION COLLEGE STUDENTS.
EXPERIENCING HIGH RATES OF
HOMELESSNESS STATEWIDE.
WITHOUT BUILDING THE INVENTORY
OF HOUSING OPTIONS FOR YOUTH.
FOCUSING PARTICULARLY ON SCALING
INTERVENTIONS WITH HIGHER RATES
OF SUCCESS SUCH AS RAPIDLY
HOUSING.
MANY OF OUR YOUNG PEOPLE WILL
CONTINUE TO EXPERIENCE
HOMELESSNESS ANY THEM FOR LONGER
AND LONGER DURATIONS.
OUR INVESTMENTS IN HOUSING AND
SERVICES FOR YOUTH EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS SHOULD ALLOW
COMMUNITIES THE FLEXIBILITY THEY
NEED TO TAILOR SERVICES TO THE
UNIQUE NEEDS OF YOUNG ADULTS.
YOUNG PEOPLE OFTEN EXPERIENCE
HOMELESSNESS DIFFERENTLY THAN
THEIR ADULT COUNTERPARTS.
THE MORE DIFFICULT TO IDENTIFY
AND THE REQUIRED DEVELOPMENTALLY
APPROPRIATE SERVICES AND
ENGAGEMENT STRATEGIES.
YOUNG PEOPLE OFTEN TIMES NEED
MORE TIME TO STABILIZE AND
HOUSING.
AND BUILD THE SKILLS AND ASSETS
THEY NEED TO ACHIEVE SELF
SUFFICIENCY.
LIKE AB THREE OH SEVEN ANY
INVESTMENTS IN PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES FOR YOUTH EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS MUST ALLOW THE
FLEXIBLE PROGRAM DESIGNS AND
ENSURE SERVICES ARE TAILORED TO
THE YOUTH AND YOUNG ADULT
POPULATION.
FURTHER WE MUST ENSURE THE
SERVICES ARE LOW BARRIER.
DEVELOPMENTALLY APPROPRIATE
TRAUMA AND FORMS AND CULTURALLY
COMPETENT TO ENSURE THAT.
YOUTH WHO ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED.
BY EXPERIENCE OF HOMELESSNESS
INCLUDING YOUTH OF COLOR LGBTQ
YOUTH PARENTING YOUTH AND YOUTH
EXPERIENCING MENTAL HEALTH
CHALLENGES USING SUBSTANCES CAN
ACCESS THESE SERVICES. TO
ADDRESS YOUTH HOMELESSNESS IN
OUR COMMUNITIES FROM A SYSTEM
LANDS.
IT'S ALSO IMPERATIVE THAT WE
LOOK TO THE MAINSTREAM SYSTEMS
THAT PLAY A CRITICAL ROLE IN
BOTH PREVENTING EXPERIENCES OF
YOUTH HOMELESSNESS.
AND CONTRIBUTING TO YOUNG
PERSONS PATHWAY OUT OF
HOMELESSNESS.
AMONG THE MOST IMPACTFUL
MAINSTREAM SYSTEMS ON THE
OVERALL LANDSCAPE OF YOUTH
HOMELESSNESS IS CHILD WELFARE.
STILL A STUDIES ON THE
CONNECTIONS BETWEEN YOUTH
HOMELESSNESS AND FOSTER CARE
STATUS HAVE FOUND THAT CURRENT
AND FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS AT
HIGHER RATES THAN THEIR PEERS.
MANY YOUNG PEOPLE EXPERIENCE
HOMELESSNESS IMMEDIATELY OR SOON
AFTER EXITING.
CARE PARTICULARLY YOUTH AGING
OUT OF FOSTER CARE INCLUDING
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE. ONE STUDY
FOUND THAT 22% OF YOUTH EXITING
THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM IN
THREE MIDWESTERN STATES
INCLUDING ONE STATE WITH
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE.
EXPERIENCE AT LEAST ONE EPISODE
OF HOMELESSNESS WITHIN ONE YEAR
OF EXITING THE SYSTEM.
THE PIPELINE FROM FOSTER CARE
YOUTH HOMELESSNESS IS CERTAINLY
PARENT LA COUNTY.
WHERE MORE THAN 40% OF THE
PARTICIPANTS IN THE YOUTH COURT
EIGHT ENTRY SYSTEM REPORT THAT
THEY'VE HAD A SOCIAL WORKER IN
THEIR LIFETIME?
A PORTION OF WHOM WOULD HAVE
EMANCIPATED AT AGE NINE EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN OR TWENTY OR WOULD HAVE
AGED OUT OF THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM AT TWENTY ONE LASSEN
COUNTY PARTNERS ARE WORKING
CLOSELY WITH --
LA COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF CHILDREN
AND FAMILY SERVICES TO ENSURE
GREATER HOUSING STABILITY FOR
YOU THAT THEY ACTUALLY CARE BY
ENHANCING THE DISCHARGE PLANNING
PROCESS AND INTEGRATING A
SEAMLESS CONNECTION TO HOUSING
RESOURCE. THREE THREE USED YOUTH
THE S. WHERE APPROPRIATE AS
YOUNG PEOPLE ACTED CARE.
HOWEVER THE REMAINS THE NEED FOR
A TRIAL OUR CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEMS TO MAKE GREATER
INVESTMENTS IN AND REDUCE
BARRIERS TO THE SHORT.
MEDIUM AND LONG TERM HOUSING
STABILITY FOR KERR.
THIS IS MOST CRITICAL FOR YOUTH
AND EXITED FOSTER CARE AS YOU
STATEWIDE OF ELECTED TO
REMAINING CARE UNTIL THEY'RE
TWENTY FIRST BIRTHDAY.
AT A SIGNIFICANT RATE.
IN FISCAL YEAR 272-201-71880 2%
OF YOUNG PEOPLE REMAINED AN
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE UPON
TURNING.
EIGHTEEN THAT'S HIGHER THAN THE
TAKE OPERATE THAT THE STATE HAD
ORIGINALLY ANTICIPATED WHEN
IMPLEMENTING SENATE VOTES
CURRENT.
TWENTY TWELVE WELL IT'S
ENCOURAGING THAT YOUNG PEOPLE
pARE CHOOSING TO REMAIN IN CARING
CONTINUE TO ACCESS THE SERVICES.
SUCH SIGNIFICANT PARTICIPATION
HAS EXACERBATED SHORTAGES OF IN
HOUSING RESOURCES AND HOUSING
RELATED SUPPORTIVE SERVICES FOR
YOUTH IN CARE.
IT'S CRITICAL THAT WE RESOURCE
AND WORK WITH OUR PUBLIC CHILD
WELFARE AGENCIES TO BOTH ADDRESS
THE SHORTAGES AND ENSURE YOUNG
PEOPLE ARE BETTER SUPPORTED.
REMAIN STABLE HOUSE AFTER THE
ACCIDENT.
ON THE SYSTEM.
AB.
FIVE THIRTY ONE AUTHORED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN AND
SPONSORED BY CHILDREN NOW AN
ALLIANCE FOR CHILDREN'S RIGHTS.
WE TAKE AN IMPORTANT STEP IN
ENSURING COUNTY PUBLIC CHILD
WELFARE AGENCIES COMPREHENSIVELY
ASSESS THE IMMEDIATE AND LONG
TERM HOUSING NEEDS OF YOUTH AND
EXTEND FOSTER CARE.
AND MAKE INVESTMENTS TO ADDRESS
THESE HOUSING NEEDS.
IN SUMMARY I'D LIKE TO CLOSE
WITH THREE RECOMMENDATIONS.
FIRST WE MUST CLOSE THE GAP
BETWEEN THE LEVEL OF NEED AMONG
YOUTH AND YOUNG ADULTS FOR
HOUSING RESOURCES AND SERVICES.
AND A LIMITED SUPPLY OF SUCH
RESOURCES.
SECOND OUR INVESTMENTS IN THESE
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES.
SHOULD ALLOW COMMUNITIES THE
FLEXIBILITY TO ADDRESS THEIR
PART MOST PRESSING NEEDS SHOULD
BE TAILORED TO THE DEVELOPMENTAL
NEEDS OF YOUNG PEOPLE.
AND SHOULD BE LOW BARRIER TRAUMA
INFORMED AND CULTURALLY
COMPETENT.
THIRD AND FINALLY WE MUST WORK
WITH OUR MAINSTREAM SYSTEMS SUCH
AS CHILD WELFARE WHICH SERVE AS
A FEEDER INTO AN A PATHWAY OUT
OF HOMELESSNESS FOR YOUTH. TO RE
ORIENT THEMSELVES TOWARDS THE
HOUSING NEEDS OF THE YOUNG
PEOPLE THEY SERVE.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF MY NAME'S ALEXANDER HERNDON
I'M A HOUSING POLICY ADVOCATE
WITH THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY.
THE WESTERN CENTER SERVES LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIA'S IN THE AREAS
OF HEALTHCARE PUBLIC BENEFITS
AND HOUSING --
AND PRIOR TO JOINING WESTERN
CENTER I I WORKED AS A LEGAL AID
ATTORNEY IN LOS ANGELES ON
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT ISSUES [inaudible]
GOOD OKAY I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY
THANKING YOU FOR CONVENING THIS
COMMITTEE --
AND HOLDING THIS HEARING ON ONE
OF CALIFORNIA'S MOST PRESSING
ISSUES.
OUR HOUSING CRISIS HAS AFFECTED
OUR ENTIRE STATE BUT IS HIT
HARDEST FOR LOW INCOME FAMILIES
STRUGGLING TO KEEP UP WITH
RISING RENTS AND A LACK OF
AVAILABLE AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
CALIFORNIA PRIDES ITSELF ON ITS
PROGRESSIVE VALUES AND PROVIDING
A PATH TO SUCCESS FOR CHILDREN
REGARDLESS OF THEIR BACKGROUND --
AND STABLE DIVERSE COMMUNITIES
ARE A CRITICAL COMPONENT TO
ENSURING THIS VISION IS REALIZED.
HOWEVER OUR HOUSING CRISIS IS
MAKING THE CALIFORNIA DREAM
IMPOSSIBLE FOR OUR LOWEST INCOME
FAMILIES EVEN WHEN THEY'RE ABLE
TO SECURE A SYSTEMS THE PROMISES
TO HELP THEM AFFORD AN APARTMENT
ON THE PRIVATE MARKET.
MANY FAMILIES ARE UNABLE TO FIND
HOUSING EVEN WITH HOUSING
ASSISTANCE DID A BLANKET
POLICIES OF LANDLORDS.
WHO REFUSED TO LET THEM APPLY
FOR HOUSING EVEN IF THE
ASSISTANCE MEANS THEY CAN AFFORD
THE RENT?
I HAVE PERSONALLY COUNCIL
COUNTLESS TENANTS STRUGGLING TO
FIND A LAND LORD WILLING TO
ACCEPT A HOUSING VOUCHER OR
OTHER ASSISTANCE.
BEFORE THEY'RE FORCED TO RETURN
IT ON USE.
THIS IS BEEN ESPECIALLY
FRUSTRATING FOR CERTAIN GROUPS
OF TENANTS INCLUDING THOSE WITH
CHILDREN.
WHO COUNT ON THIS ASSISTANCE --
TO SHIELD THEM FROM THE
UNCERTAINTY AND DISRUPTION OF
LIVING IN AN UNSTABLE
ENVIRONMENT.
WE'VE HEARD FROM PREVIOUS
SPEAKERS POWERFUL STORIES ABOUT
THE EFFECTS THAT HOUSING AND
SECURITY HOUSE ON YOUNG CHILDREN.
AND THIS IS REFLECTED IN THE
FACES OF PARENTS I MET WHO WORRY.
ABOUT THEIR CHILDREN BEING
DISTRACTED FROM SCHOOL AND
FAMILY NETWORKS SUBJECTED TO THE
STRESS OF AN UNSUITABLE
ENVIRONMENT.
OR FORCED INTO HOMELESSNESS
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T FIND A
LANDLORD WILLING TO ACCEPT THEIR
ASSISTANCE.
AS WE WORK TO ADDRESS OUR
HOUSING CRISIS WE MUST
PRIORITIZE SOLUTIONS THAT
ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF THOSE MOST
VULNERABLE TO ITS EFFECTS.
BUILDING MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
WILL TAKE TIME AND STRUGGLING
FAMILIES RIGHT NOW DON'T HAVE
TIME TO WAIT A CHILD CANNOT PUT
THEIR CHILDHOOD ON HOLD WHILE WE
BUILD ON AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNIT.
OR WAIT FOR THE MARKET TO ADJUST.
AND SOLUTIONS THAT ALLOW LOW
INCOME FAMILIES TO ACCESS
EXISTING HOUSING OR CRITICAL
COMPONENT TO ENSURING THEIR
CHILDREN SUCCEED. TO THAT END SB
THREE TWENTY NINE THE HOUSING
OPPORTUNITIES OCT REPRESENTS A
KEY SOLUTION THAT CAN HELP
STRUGGLING FAMILIES RIGHT NOW.
WHILE WE ADDRESS HOUSING SUPPLY.
THE BILL WOULD INSTITUTE A
PROVEN SOLUTION BY INCLUDING
HOUSING ASSISTANCE AS A
PROTECTED SOURCE OF INCOME UNDER
THE FAIR EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING
ACT.
AND THE EFFECT OF THIS CHANGE
WOULD BE TO PROHIBIT
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST FAMILIES
BASED ON THE FACT THAT THEY
RECEIVE HOUSING ASSISTANCE.
I AM WOULD REQUIRE THAT
ASSISTANCE TO BE TREATED THE
SAME AS ANY OTHER FORM OF INCOME.
THIS MEANS THAT WHILE LANDLORDS
COULD STILL SCREEN ASSISTED
FAMILIES USING THE SAME CRITERIA
THEY USE FOR ANY OTHER HOUSING
APPLICANT.
THEY WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO BAR
THESE FAMILIES FROM APPLYING
JUST BECAUSE THEY GET HELP
PAYING THE RENT.
SB THREE TWENTY NINTHS CHANGE TO
SEE HOW I WAS LISTED AS THE
NUMBER ONE HOUSING
RECOMMENDATION OF THE LIFTING
FAMILIES WITH CHILDREN OUT OF
POVERTY TASK FORCE.
AND IT'S AND THE POLICY HAS A
PROVEN RECORD OF SUCCESS WHERE
IT'S BEEN IMPLEMENTED. ELEVEN
STATES AND OVER FIFTY LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS INCLUDING SEVERAL
IN CALIFORNIA.
HAVE IMPLEMENTED SOURCE OF
INCOME PROTECTIONS AND THEIR
EFFECT ON THE ABILITY OF
FAMILIES TO SUCCESSFULLY OBTAIN
STABLE HOUSING HAS BEEN DRAMATIC.
A RECENT STUDY BY THE US
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND URBAN
DEVELOPMENT FOUND THAT WITHOUT
SOURCE OF INCOME PROTECTIONS
APPROXIMATELY 77%OF FAMILIES
WERE REJECTED BY LANDLORDS AND
UNABLE TO USE THEIR SECTION
EIGHT VOUCHERS.
IN JURISDICTIONS WITH THIS
POLICY IN PLACE.
THAT REJECTION RATE PLUMMETED
235%.
IN ADDITION RESEARCH SHOWS THAT
THE POLICY CAN SIGNIFICANTLY
IMPROVE THE ABILITY OF ASSISTED
FAMILIES TO ACCESS LOW POVERTY
HIGH OPPORTUNITY NEIGHBORHOODS.
IN CALIFORNIA OVER THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND HOUSEHOLDS RECEIVE
SECTION EIGHT ASSISTANCE ALONE.
AND MANYMORE RECEIVE ASSISTANCE --
THROUGH OTHER PROGRAMS INCLUDING
THOSE ADMINISTERED BY THE STATE
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS --
AND WITH A RANGE OF JURISDICTION
STEPPING UP TO ADDRESS OUR
HOUSING CRISIS THROUGH THESE
PROGRAMS IT'S ESSENTIAL THAT WE
MAKE SURE THAT THAT ASSISTANCE
CAN ACTUALLY BE USED BY NEEDY
FAMILIES.
HOUSING ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS HELP
FAMILIES AFFORD RENT ON THE
PRIVATE MARKET AND ACCESS AREAS
OF OPPORTUNITY BY REQUIRING
RECIPIENTS TO PAY ABOUT 30% OF
THEIR INCOME IN RENT.
AND THE REMAINDER OF THE RENT IS
PROVIDED BY A LOCAL HOUSING
AUTHORITY OR OTHER AGENCY
DIRECTLY TO THE LANDMARK.
THIS ALLOWS FAMILIES TO ENSURE
THEY'RE SUFFICIENT INCOME LEFT
OVER AFTER PAYING THE RENT --
TO PAY FOR BASIC NECESSITIES
SUCH AS FOOD AND MEDICAL CARE%
TRANSPORTATION AND CLOTHING AND
TURN ALLOWING THEIR CHILDREN TO
FOCUS ON THEIR EDUCATION AND
DEVELOPMENT.
WHEN FAMILIES ARE ABLE TO
COMFORTABLY AFFORD THEIR RENT
RESEARCH SHOWS THEY'RE MORE
LIKELY TO MAKE EXPENDITURES ON
HEALTH CARE AND HEALTHY FOOD
INCREASING RANGE OF HEALTH THE
HEALTH AND EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES
FOR THEIR CHILDREN?
IN ADDITION HOUSING ASSISTANCE
PROGRAMS PROTECT CHILDREN'S
HEALTH AND OUR OVERALL HOUSING
STOCK.
BY PERFORMING A BASIC INSPECTION
OF EACH ASSISTED UNIT TO ENSURE
IT MEETS THE LEGAL REQUIREMENTS
FOR HEALTHY HOUSING.
AS A RESULT OF THE STABILITY
PROVIDED BY AFFORDABLE AND
PREDICTABLE HOUSING COSTS LOW
INCOME FAMILIES WITH HOUSING
ASSISTANCE TYPICALLY REMAIN IN
THEIR UNITS LONGER THAN THE
AVERAGE TENANT PROVIDING
CERTAINTY TO PARTICIPATING
LANDLORDS.
SOME JURISDICTIONS HAVE FOUND
THAT WHILE LOCAL LANDLORDS WERE
INITIALLY RESISTANT TO A SOURCE
OF INCOME POLICY.
ONCE IT WAS IN PLACE THEY WERE
SATISFIED WITH THE GUARANTEED ON
TIME PAYMENTS RECEIVED UNDER
THESE ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS.
BOTH FROM TENANTS MORE ABLE TO
AFFORD THEIR PORTION OF THE RENT
AND FROM GOVERNMENT AGENCIES
ENSURING THE REMAINDER IS PAID
IN FULL AND ON TIME.
THE HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES ACT
PROVIDES A CHANCE FOR LOW INCOME
FAMILIES WITH HOUSING ASSISTANCE
TO ACCESS HIGH OPPORTUNITY
NEIGHBORHOODS AND STABLE HOUSING.
LEADING TO IMPROVED OUTCOMES FOR
THEIR CHILDREN BY ENSURING
THEY'RE ABLE TO APPLY FOR
HOUSING IN THE SAME WAY OTHER
FAMILIES CAN.
STRUGGLING CALIFORNIANS SHOULD
NOT BE FORCED TO GIVE UP THEIR
HOUSING ASSISTANCE SIMPLY
pLORD WILLING TO ACCEPT IT
PUTTING THEIR CHILDREN AT RISK.
THE WESTERN CENTER APPLAUDS
LEGISLATURE'S ATTENTION TO THESE
CRITICAL ISSUES AND ENCOURAGES
YOUR SUPPORT OF SB THREE TWENTY
NINE AND OTHER MEASURES TO
ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA'S
CHILDREN LIVING IN POVERTY ARE
PROTECTED FROM DISCRIMINATION.
AND ARE ABLE TO GROW UP IN A
STABLE HEALTHY AND AFFORDABLE
HOME THANK YOU.
COLLEAGUES.
MR HARDEN WOULDN'T GIVE ME ANY
LOVE BUT I WANT TO KNOW THE
THREE TWENTY DIED AS A MITCHELL
BILL SO I HOPE I CAN COUNT ON
YOUR SUPPORT.
AND TO THE FINAL WORD TODAY WILL
BE FROM OUR LA ELS OFFICE.
AND HAULING TO IT THANK YOU IN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR --
SO YOU SHOULD HAVE A HAND OUT IN
FRONT OF YOU TODAY THAT I'LL BE
SPEAKING FROM.
I'M GOING TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT
THE PROPER COMMENT PROGRAM WHICH
IS A SPECIFIC PROGRAM BUT IN THE
CONTEXT OF THIS BROADER
CONVERSATION THAT YOU'RE HAVING.
ABOUT HOUSING AFFORDABILITY
PARTICULARLY FOR FAMILIES WITH
CHILDREN --
IT SO THE PROPERTY TAX
POSTPONEMENT PROGRAM IS ONE THAT
IS CURRENTLY ADMINISTERED BY THE
STATE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE AND
ALLOW CERTAIN ELIGIBLE
HOMEOWNER'S. TO DEFERRED THE
PAYMENT OF THEIR PROPERTY TAXES
INDEFINITELY.
THE WAY THIS WORKS IS --
A HOMEOWNER WILL APPLY TO THE
STATE IF THEY ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
THE PROGRAM THE STATE WILL PAY
THEIR PROPERTY TAX PAYMENTS
DIRECTLY ON THEIR BEHALF WITH
THE COUNTY.
THE HOMEOWNER DOES NOT NEED TO
REPAY -- AND
LAST THEY MOVE OUT OF THEIR HOME
OR SELL THE HOME R THE HOME IS
AND HEARD IT OR THERE'S SOME
OTHER CONDITIONS --
BUT THE HOMEOWNER DOES
EVENTUALLY REPAIR THEIR ERRORS
WOULD REPAY THE STATE WITH
INTEREST FOR THE PROGRAM.
SO TURNING TO THE FIRST PAGE OF
THE HANDOUT I'M JUST TO GIVE A
LITTLE BIT OF CONTACTS BUT TWO
IS TO START.
AND THEN ALL DELEGATED TO
SPECIFICALLY OUR EVALUATION OF
THE PROPERTY TAX POSTPONEMENT
AND HIGHLIGHTS AND KEY ASPECTS
OF THE EVALUATION IN LIGHT OF
THIS -- THIS
BROADER DISCUSSION.
SO -- OF
COURSE AS YOU'VE BEEN DISCUSSING
A HOUSING IS VERY EXPENSIVE IN
CALIFORNIA --
PROPERTY TAX PAYMENTS ARE
SOMEWHAT LESS SO AND THAT'S
BECAUSE OF PROPOSITION THIRTEEN
WHICH LIMITS THE GROWTH OF THE
ASSESSED VALUE OF A PROPERTY
OVER TIME.
ALTHOUGH PROPERTY TAXES PAID ARE
STILL ABOVE THE NATIONAL AVERAGE --
IN CALIFORNIA.
SO THE PROPERTY TAX POSTPONEMENT%
PROGRAM HELPS OR TO THEIR
PROPERTY TAXES IF THEY MEET
CERTAIN CRITERIA.
THE FIRST IS THAT THEY HAVE TO
BE OVER THE AGE OF SIXTY TWO
BLIND OR DISABLED.
THE SECOND IS THAT THEY HAVE TO
HAVE HOUSEHOLD INCOME LESS THAN
THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
500-355-35000 FIVE HUNDRED PER
MONTH.
PER YEAR EXCUSE ME THAT WOULD BE
CRAZY -- AND
FINALLY THEY HAVE TO OWN AT
LEAST 40% EQUITY IN THEIR HOMES.
SO THE TABLE AT THE BOTTOM OF
THE AGE JUST PROVIDES OUR
OFFICES EVALUATION OF THIS
PROGRAM AND I'M NOT GONNA TALK
THROUGH EACH OF THESE --
CRITERIA SPECIFICALLY BUT JUST
HIGHLIGHT SOME OF THE ONES THAT
ARE PARTICULARLY RELEVANT FOR
THIS CONVERSATION.
SO ON ELIGIBILITY WE FIND THAT --
THIS INCOME ELIGIBILITY
THRESHOLD FOR THE P. FOR PTP.
IT DOES NOT VERY BY HOUSEHOLD
SIZE IT IS NOT VERY BY GEOGRAPHY
AND IT DOES NOT VERY OVER TIME
TO ACCOUNT FOR INFLATION.
THERE'S OBVIOUSLY SOME
CHALLENGES HERE THE FIRST BEING
AT THAT LARGER HOUSEHOLDS ARE
ARE CLEARLY GOING TO NEED MORE
RESOURCES TO MEET THE EXPENSES --
UP ALL OF THEIR OF ALL OF THE
PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN THEM SO A
FAMILY OF SIX IS OBVIOUSLY GOING.
TO YOU KNOW PERHAPS HAVE MORE
AFFORDABILITY CHALLENGES THAN A
FAMILY OF ONE OR TWO AND THEN
ALSO WE FIND A LOWER INCOME
HOMEOWNERS PAY MORE AS A SHARE
OF THEIR INCOME TOWARD PROPERTY
TAXES IF THEY LIVE IN HIGH COST.
AND HIGH INCOME AREAS OF THE
STATE IN OTHER AREAS SO IT MIGHT
MAKE SENSE SIMILAR TO OTHER
HOUSING PROGRAMS FOR THE TOP
INCOME THRESHOLD TO VARY BY
GEOGRAPHY.
ON THE AGE LIMIT SPECIFICALLY WE
FIND THE YOUNGER HOMEOWNERS
COULD PROBABLY BENEFIT JUST AS
MUCH IF NOT MORE FROM THIS
PROGRAM IS OLDER HOMEOWNERS.
TO AND THE REASON FOR THIS IS
THAT -- LOW
INCOME HOMEOWNERS IN THEIR
FORTIES AND FIFTIES ACTUALLY PAY
A MUCH HIGHER SHARE OF THEIR
INCOME TOWARD PROPERTY TAX
PAYMENTS THAN THOSE WHO ARE OVER.
SIXTY BASICALLY BECAUSE OF PROP
THIRTEEN AGAIN RIGHT THE LONGER
THAT YOU'VE ON THE HOME ON THE
LOWER YOUR AFFECTED PROPERTY TAX
PAYMENT IS GOING TO BE.
AND SO WE WOULD JUST SAY THAT
PERHAPS THE P. T. P. INCOME
ELIGIBILITY COULD BE EXPANDED TO
PEOPLE BELOW THE AGE OF SIXTY
TWO BUT THERE'S OBVIOUSLY A
NEXUS HERE SPECIFICALLY FOR
FAMILIES WITH CHILDREN ONE BEING
THAT MULTI GENERATIONAL
HOUSEHOLDS ARE GOING TO BE LESS
LIKELY TO BE ABLE. TO QUALIFY
UNDER THE CURRENT CONSTRUCTION
OF THE PROGRAM BECAUSE
EVERYBODY'S INCOME IN THE
HOUSEHOLD COUNTS TOWARDS THE
LIMIT.
AND THE SECOND BEING THAT OF
COURSE CHILDREN TIME TO LIVE IN
HOMES WHERE THE HEAD OF
HOUSEHOLD IS UNDER THE AGE OF
SIXTY TWO AND SO EXPANDING THE
INCOME ARE THE AGE ELIGIBILITY.
IS POSSIBLY GOING TO BENEFIT
FAMILIES WITH CHILDREN AS WELL --
JUST QUICKLY ON AFFORDABILITY IN
THE BUDGETARY ASPECTS OF THE
PROGRAM.
THE P. T. P. INTEREST RATE IS 7%
WHICH WE FIND IS TOO HIGH --
ALTHOUGH I WOULD NOTE THAT
AFFORDABILITY OF THIS PROGRAM IS
ACTUALLY A BIT --
BETTER THAN COMPARABLE PROGRAMS
LIKE REVERSE MORTGAGES REVERSE
MORTGAGES TEND TO BE ACTUALLY
EVEN MORE EXPENSIVE THAN PCP.
AND ON THE BUDGETARY ASPECTS OF
THE PROGRAM PTP DOES NOT KERRY
COST TO TAXPAYERS THAT'S BECAUSE
REPAYMENTS ON OUTSTANDING LOANS
COVER THE COST OF MAKING NEW
LOANS TO NEW PARTICIPANTS --
AND ACTUALLY PTP PROVIDE THE
GENERAL FUND BENEFIT.
THERE IS --
A FUN TO THAT FUNDS ACCESS OF A
CERTAIN LIMIT IS SWEPT TO THE
GENERAL FUND SO RATHER THAN
GENERAL FUND TAXPAYERS
SUPPORTING PT PPTP IS SUPPORTING.
GENERAL FUND TAXPAYERS.
THE FINAL PAGE ARE JUST PRESENTS
SOME ALTERNATIVES TO CHANGE PTP
IN LIGHT OF THIS EVALUATION I'M
NOT GOING TO WALK THROUGH THIS --
IN DETAIL FOR THE SAKE OF TIME.
BUT I'LL JUST HIGHLIGHT SOME
SPECIFIC --
IDEAS HERE ADVANCES US SOME
SPECIFIC CHANGES THAT MIGHT NEED
TO BE MADE WITH RESPECT TO
AFFORDABILITY AND GENERAL FUND
SUPPORT SPECIFICALLY.
SO THE FOUR DIFFERENT CATEGORIES
ARE MAINTAINING ELIGIBILITY AS
IT EXISTS CURRENTLY CHANGING
INCOME THRESHOLD SO THAT THEY
WOULD VERY BY HOUSEHOLD SIZE ARE
VERY BY GEOGRAPHY AND VERY OVER
TIME.
POSSIBLY ALSO RAISE THE AVERAGE
INCOME THRESHOLD A BIT BECAUSE
THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED IS QUITE LOW.
ALLOWING YOUNGER HOMEOWNERS TO
PARTICIPATE WHICH THERE ARE SOME
TECHNICAL ASPECTS HERE BUT THAT
COULD POSSIBLY REQUIRE A
CONSTITUTIONAL REVISION THIS
PROGRAM IS --
I WAS CREATED ORIGINALLY UNDER
THE CONSTITUTION --
AND THEN OF COURSE YOU COULD
MAKE BOTH OF THESE CHANGES SO IN
TERMS OF THE INTEREST RATE WE
THINK THE INTEREST RATE COULD BE
LOWER -- IN
VARIOUS PERMUTATIONS OF THIS
PROGRAM PARTICULARLY IF YOU WERE
JUST MAKING CHANGES AROUND
ELIGIBILITY OP WITH RESPECT TO
INCOME.
BUT WITH RESPECT TO ALLOWING
YOUNGER HOMEOWNERS TO
PARTICIPATE IT'S POSSIBLE THAT
THIS WOULD INTRODUCE SOME
ADDITIONAL RISK TO THE STATE.
AND THAT'S BECAUSE YOUNGER
HOMEOWNERS ARE GONNA TEND TO
HOLD THESE LOANS FOR A LONGER
AND POSSIBLY --
MEAN THAT THE THE VALUE OF THE
LOAN WILL EXCEED THE VALUE OF
THE EQUITY THAT THEY HOLD IN
THEIR HOME.
AND SO AS A RESULT WE HAVE JUST
A COUPLE OF RECOMMENDATIONS
AROUND LIMITING STATE RISK --
AT THAT COULD KEEP THE FIND
GENERALLY SELF FUNDED AS IT IS
CURRENTLY --
BUT IT ALSO EITHER OF THESE OP
ELIGIBILITY COULD REQUIRE ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND SUPPORT JUST --
TO ON A SHORT TERM BASIS TO
ALLOW -- THE
INCREASED ELIGIBILITY AN
INCREASED PARTICIPATION
ASSOCIATED WITH THE PROGRAM TO
STABILIZE OVER TIME SO --
WITHOUT A BE HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
HAVE BEEN JOINED BY CENTER TYLER.
QUICK QUESTION --
BUDGET PARTICIPATION YOUR CHART
SAYS IS VERY LOW AROUND A
THOUSAND PARTICIPANTS IN THE
MOST RECENT YEAR.
IS THAT BECAUSE WE'VE SO
NARROWLY DEFINED WHO QUALIFIES
LACK ABOUT REACH WHY DO YOU
THINK THAT IS YEAH --
THERE'S A COUPLE ISSUES HERE SO
DESPITE THE FACT THAT OVER A
MILLION CALIFORNIANS QUALIFY FOR
THIS PROGRAM I'M HERE --
ONLY A THOUSAND PARTICIPATED IN
THE MOST RECENT YEAR ONE ISSUE
IS THAT THE PROGRAM HAS ACTUALLY
EXISTED SINCE NINETEEN SEVENTY
SIX I BELIEVE OR NINETEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT SEVENTY SIX BUT IT
WAS SUSPENDED IN --
TWO THOUSAND NINE AS A RESULT OF
GENERAL FUND BUDGET PRESSURE AND
THEN IT WAS REINSTATED IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN AND SO PART OF THE
ISSUE THERE MIGHT JUST BE THE
FACT THAT THE PROGRAM WAS
SUSPENDED AND REINSTATED MEANS
THAT AWARENESS IS LOWER THAN IT
COULD BE --
BUT ALSO PART OF IT MIGHT BE
THAT THE PEOPLE WHO REALLY COULD
BENEFIT FROM THE PROGRAM THE
MOST DON'T HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO ACCESS IT.
WHAT WHAT WE CONSIDER ALL OF THE
MONEY WE SPEND AN OUT REACH FOR
EITC THE NEW STATE IN EARNED
INCOME TAX CREDIT IT SEEMS LIKE
THIS WOULD BE?
A ANOTHER VIABLE TOOL THAT WE
NEED TO PROBABLY DIRECT FROM
RESOURCES ONE MORE QUICK
QUESTION --
OPEN UP FROM MY COLLEAGUES.
THE 40% EQUITY IN THEIR HOMES TO
SEE ME HE SAID YOU'RE TRYING TO
CALCULATE AND MY 40% EQUITY YET
PROBABLY NOT.
BUT IF YOU MOVE TO A YOUNGER
POPULATION WHAT'S THE LIKELIHOOD
THAT THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO MEET
THAT.
CRITERIA I'D BE CONCERNED YEAH
ABSOLUTELY SO --
ONE OF THE REASONS THAT THAT
CRITERIA IS REASONABLE FOR THE
CURRENT POPULATION IS THAT
THEY'RE OLDER AND SO THEY'VE ON
THEIR HOMES FOR A LONGER.
YEAH THAT IS SOMETHING THAT
WE'VE CONSIDERED AN THOUGHT THAT
YOU MIGHT NEED TO LOWER THAT
THRESHOLD IF --
YOU WANTED TO CHANGE THE AGE
ELIGIBILITY THAT WOULD AGAIN
INTRODUCED MORE STATE RISK SO
THERE'S REALLY JUST A BALANCING
ACT THERE BETWEEN --
ENSURING THAT THIS THE PROGRAM
HAS ENOUGH FUNDING TO CONTINUE --
AS A RESULT OF ALL THE VARIOUS
RISKS THAT IT FACES BUT THEN
ALSO ENSURING THAT PEOPLE HAVE
ACCESS.
EXCELLENT ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
SOME TO CABALLERO THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR.
I'M I I IN I APOLOGIZE IF THIS
ISN'T THE RIGHT JOB HEARING TO
HAVE THIS QUESTION BUT I I AM.
THAT I WANTED TO ASK --
MR HARDIN ON SB THREE TWENTY
NINE NINE YOU KNOW IT'S IT'S
YOUR BILL BUT I I WAS VERY --
INTRIGUED BY THE TESTIMONY OF
ELDER MCNEIL AS SHE TESTIFIED TO
THE SHENANIGANS THAT WERE PLAYED
WITH THEIR SECTION.
EIGHT AND AND I'M WONDERING.
BECAUSE IT IS A FEDERAL PROGRAM
WE DON'T HAVE A LOT OF AUTHORITY
SAY THOU SHALT NOT.
BUT IT SEEMS TO ME THAT IF WE
MAKE -- A IT
WE WE USE THE DEFINITION AND
UNDER THREE TWENTY NINE BUT SOME
OF THAT MAY BE.
AT IT UNLAWFUL FOR THEM TO DO.
AND THEN WE WOULD WANT TO COME
FIGURE OUT A WAY TO CREATE
PENALTIES IF PEOPLE PLAY AROUND
WITH YEAH I'M GONNA TAKE YOUR
SECTION --
EIGHT BUT YOU CAN GET THE PAPER
PAPERWORK RIGHT OR YES I'M GONNA
TAKE IT BUT NOW I'M I HAVE NOT
PAID.
THE MORTGAGE AND YOU CAN BE
TURNED OUT WITHIN TWENTY FOUR
HOURS I MEAN THAT THAT PART OF
THE STORY REALLY ANGERED ME AND
I I KNOW WE'VE HEARD THOSE KINDS
OF STORIES WORKING IN LEGAL AID
FOR MANY YEARS.
THE QUESTION IS CAN WE PUT TEETH
IN SOMETHING.
SO IF YOU DO IT.
YOU'RE PAYING A BIGGER PENALTY
DOWN THE ROAD AND AND THERE ARE
THEIR CONSEQUENCE ALMOST
WONDERING IF THE IF IF IF IT'S
NOT IN THERE IS THERE SOMETHING
WE CAN ADD SO THAT WE DON'T NEED
TO CHANGE THE FEDERAL.
LAW WE JUST ADD OUR OWN
PROTECTIONS IN CALIFORNIA.
RIGHT WELL I THINK I THINK.
THERE THERE'VE BEEN EXPERIENCES
WITH LOCAL JURISDICTIONS THAT
HAVE IMPLEMENTED THIS PLICY --
AND THEY HAVE FOUND THAT
ENFORCEMENT HAS BEEN SUCCESSFUL
AND NOT OVERLY BURDENSOME THINK.
IT DOESN'T TAKE THAT MANY
ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS UNDER THIS
KIND OF A POLICY TAKE FOR THE
MESSAGE TO GET SENT THAT.
YOU KNOW LANDLORDS NEED TO TREAT
THIS FAMILY IS THE SAME AS AS
PEOPLE WHO HAVE ANY OTHER SOURCE
OF INCOME --
AND SANTA MONICA HAS HAD A
PRETTY SUCCESSFUL EFFORT --
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH LOCAL LEGAL
AID PROGRAMS --
TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT TENANTS
ARE SPECTER THAN THAT AND THAT
THEY'RE ACTUALLY THIS POLICY IS
LEADING TO THEM.
TRULY BEING ABLE TO ACCESS
HOUSING UNITS.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME YOUR TESTIMONY TODAY YOU'VE
GIVEN US LOTS OF FOOD FOR
THOUGHT WE ALWAYS LIKE TO
INCLUDE IN OUR HEARINGS ACTUAL
SOLUTION SO WE YOU KNOW DON'T
LEAVE HERE.
COMPLETELY YOU RIGHT OUT OF OUR
MINDS WITH NO.
LIGHT IN THE TULSA THANK YOU.
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE YOU.
ARE NOT WE ARE HAPPY TO OPEN THE
FLOOR TO PUBLIC COMMENT.
IF THERE'S SOMETHING YOU WOULD
LIKE TO ADD TO TODAY'S
DISCUSSION.
WHERE THE FLOOR MIGHT COME ON?
I JUST WANT TO KIND OF GET A
SENSE OF HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO QUEUE UP TO LET YOU
KNOW HOW MUCH TIME YOU HAVE I
SEE A LOT OF PEOPLE LOOK LIKE
THEY'RE MAKING THEIR WAY.
I'M GOING IT'LL BE LIVE WHEN I
STOP TALKING.
IN THE BILL TURN YOU LIVE I JUST
WANT TO SEE HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE
QUEUING UP SO I CAN TELL YOU.
HOW MUCH TIME YOU HAVE?
BECAUSE WE HAVE A HARD STOP AT
THREE PM.
WE WILL HONOR YOUR TIME I KNOW
PEOPLE HAVE.
TO TRAVEL BACK HOME BASED ON THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO ARE COMING
FOR WORK.
I'M GONNA GIVE EVERYONE ONE
MINUTE.
FEEL FREE OF SOMEONE WHO SPEAK
BEFORE YOU MAKES THE SAME POINT
THAT YOU WANT TO MAKE FEEL FREE
TO SAY THAT --
THAT'S AN OFFICIAL TERM HERE.
IN THE COMMITTEE PROCESS WAS
WE'VE GOT A TOTAL OF FIFTY FIRST
WITNESS.
YOUR NAME AND COMMENT PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JACKIE
LONG TIME WITH THE GRACE AND I
REALLY THANK WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR HAVING THE HEARING
TODAY MUCH OF WHAT WAS DISCUSSED
WAS ACTUALLY IN THE LIFTING
CHILDREN IN POVERTY --
TASK FORCE AND I KNOW THAT A LOT
OF YOUR ACTUALLY AUTHORING IN
SUPPORTING A LOT OF EFFORTS TO
REALLY APPRECIATE TECHNOLOGY
MEANT.
THAT --
ADDRESSING UP POVERTY IN DEEP
POVERTY IS NOT JUST AND ECONOMIC
JUSTICE ISSUE BUT IT ALSO RACIAL
JUSTICE ISSUE THAT WILL REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT.
THIS WITNESS.
TV YOUR QUICK MONICA MONICA
MONICA.
CALL THE TO THE MIKE WHEN I SAID
SHE NEVER RESTING ALL.
RIGHT THEN BYE WE'VE A COVER
FRESNO SP MEXICO.
RABBI NEVER SHE GOT YOU SEE THE
REGINA SHANINA.
THE COOL YEAH BOTTOM THING TO
YOU BUT IT'S NOT FILE SOME.
YEAH YEAH WE WELL YEAH NAVIES
THE WHAT I READ ABOUT YOU IN THE
MARKET A LOT WHEN I HAVE TO TRY
THEM FOR FRESNO AND APARTMENT SO
WITH THERE.
ARE PRETTY SPEND SAID AND ME I
WORKING FEELS.
YEAH SUMMER YEAH I MEAN THE
VALUE OF WILL BE BACK WITH ON
THE CHOPPING DATA.
ON YOU KNOW WE'D OR NOT COOL
YEAH I WE HAD TO THE COUPLE.
THE FINAL WALK WONDER PUT THEM
IN THE FRONT OF WHILE ON THE TO
SOMEONE NOBODY'S COULD NOT --
WHAT IS PERFECT FOR THIS POLICY
OKAY AND NOT THAT I AM NOT COOL?
THE YUKON YOU WILL.
NOT BE JUNE YET BANISHING THE
LAW OR NOT GOING UP YOU COPULATE
SHE QUESTIONED.
WHEN ASKED IF YOU GUYS CAN HELP
WITH THAT BECAUSE OUT?
UPPER WE LIVE IN SPREE SMALL IN
THIS VERY PRICEY AND ON MY KIDS
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH FRUIT TO DO
THEIR HOMEWORK OR EIGHT DAY.
THAT'S A MASK YOU GUYS YOU GUYS
CAN HELP ME --
AND WITH THAT MATTER
[inaudible]
THANK.
CHEN W. ME --
SIX COUNTY SEE NINE MESSAGE WILL
NOT UNLESS YOU JUST WANT WITH
THE PHONE ARE WE TALKING BUT TO
LIVE IN A AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
FACT WERE FROM OUR SAID SO.
YOU NAME IT WE HAVE IT I HAVE
COUPLE PARENTS HERE THAT THEY
WILL GIVE TESTIMONY WHICH AWARDS
TO PUT A WORD TALKED ABOUT IT.
BUT THEY ARE VERY STRUGGLE IN
MERCED COUNTY AND I KNOW THAT
SMASHED THE COMBO THROW CENTRAL
VALLEY.
AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT --
AFFORDABILITY OF HOUSING IT'S
IT'S IT'S AFFORDABLE FOR
ESPECIALLY A LOT OF OUR PARENTS
ARE REFUGEES FROM LAOS.
AND NOT BE ABLE TO HAVE THE
SKILLS TO TO HAVE A JOBS THE
RELEASE THE STING THEIR
CHILDREN'S.
IN THE HOME AND THAT'S MAKE YOU
REALLY HEARTBREAKING FOR US SO
AS AS A COMMUNITY LEADERS I WANT
TO COME BACK TO YOU AND SAY YOU
KNOW WHAT.
PLEASE DO WHATEVER YOU CAN IN
YOUR POWER TO MAKE SURE THAT F
WHICH ALSO HEARD THANK YOU.
AND I'VE COUPLE THE PARENTS WANT
TO SAY A COUPLE THINGS.
QUESTION NOW WOULD YOU M<c.cyan></c>
<c.cyan>WI MATANYA I DON'T HAVE A</c>
HOME.
CURRENTLY. TO MY HORROR WELL I
HAVE NO WORK. TO TELL JANE NOT
ATTEND.
MIGHT KNOW HOUSING ANYWHERE.
THE IMAM OR YOU MONO.
I AND SPEND THE NIGHT AT
DIFFERENT LOCATIONS.
AND THAT'S ALL I HAVE TO SAY.
WATCH --
TOOK A THANK YOU.
OF COURSE AGAINST CHINA.
THEY THOUGHT ARE THEY CANNOT
LEVEL BY THE VISION NAKAL
CHANNING I STAND ALONE.
CHECK LINE I WANT TO SAY I'VE
AYE I'M HERE IN THE COUNTRY I
WANT TO SAY.
I WANT TO ASK TO SEE IF I CAN
GET HELP THERE'S CURRENTLY.
SEVEN PEOPLE IN MY FAMILY.
GET GOING OUT LIKE THE IN GAME
HOUSING.
LIKE IT.
MY OWN MY INCOME IS ONLY TWELVE
HUNDRED AND MY RENT IS ALREADY.
IN THE KITCHEN CHANGE.
OVER A THOUSAND I DON'T HAVE
HOUSING.
I AM IN DIRE CRISIS.
ADD.
UP A BAD.
I DON'T THINK CHEN UPBRINGING
AND YET NOT TAKE THE CANCE.
AND I WANT TO ASK IS THERE ANY
HELP TO LOWER THE COST OF
HOUSING SO THAT WE CAN AFFORD
HOUSING.
AND THEN I BUDGET LOCATION UP
AND HIT J. NOTHING ON AND OFF ON
WHAT IT AND IF YOU DOWN.
THEN IT ON AND YOU AREN'T ABLE
TO HELP ARE YOU ABLE TO COME UP.
YET WHAT SHOP ONLINE NOTHING
THANK YOU THAT'S ALL.
HELLO MY NAME IS EMILY.
I FROM AS SAID AND MY HOUSE IS
TOO MUCH IF SPENCER [inaudible]
AND MY BROTHER DOWN MOVE OUT.
SO NOBODY HELP OF MY FAMILY.
MY MOM ONLY SO.
NOBODY HELP FOR OUR SO SHE'S
STRANDED AND EVERYTHING.
SO -- THEY
WANT TO KNOW IF YOU GUYS CAN
HELP US OUT.
AND PLUS THE HOUSES --
SO.
ALL THE THING CAME OUT AND YOU
KNOW IT NEVER COME.
AND FIX THE WINDOW AND NOTHING
[inaudible]
AND NOW [inaudible]
YEAH.
GO AHEAD GO LIVE YEAH THEY TOOK
TIME TAKE CARE.
WE'VE COME TO YOUR COUNTRY.
THEY CANNOT USE ROAD RUNNER
DON'T GO BY LARA.
COME TO YOUR TEN J. LACKEY
ECOLOGICAL HARUKI THIS IS THE
FIRST TIME I LOOKED TO YOU WHEN
YOU.
GET TO DO MUCH IN EVERYTHING IS
EXPENSIVE --
HOUSING IS EXPENSIVE.
FOOD IS EXPENSIVE.
WE'VE.
GIVEN ALL WE HAVE TO HOUSING
THERE'S VERY LITTLE FOR FOOD.
IT IS CHAIRED BY LARA THE HAS A
LOVE FOR YET THEY THOUGHT FOR
YOUR MOM.
THEN YOU CAN BE MEAN G. A. KOBE
HAAS.
THE REST ARE NOT THE HOPE AND
THEN THEY GOT THE WRONG THING.
SO I COME HERE I CAN SING YOU
FACE TO FACE I'M ASKING YOU. TO
SEE IF THERE'S ANYTHING YOU CAN
DO TO HELP THAT SO THAT WE CAN
REMAIN IN THIS COUNTRY WITH YOU --
DURING PUBLIC TESTIMONY ASK
SPECIFICALLY FOR HELP --
SENT A COUPLE YEAR HAS GONE TO
THE BACK AND TALK TO THE
ORGANIZATION A LEADER AND I
DIDN'T WANT TO THINK THAT I WAS.
NOT HEARING YOU AN UNDERSTANDING
YOU KNOW THE POINT OUT THE
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IS TO
EDUCATE US.
ABOUT ALL OF THESE VERY REAL
ISSUES THAT CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
ARE EXPERIENCING --
AND SO WE'VE HEARD YOU.
CENTER CABALLERO.
COMMITTED TO DOING ALL THAT SHE
CAN IN THE MEDIA TO TRY TO
PROVIDE SOME RELIEF.
THE BIG PICTURE IS WE'RE WORKING
TO TRY TO CHANGE POLICIES --
TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT WHAT WE CAN
DO TO HELP WITH THE HOUSING
ISSUE TO HELP WITH THE JOB
ACCESS ISSUE --
BUT WE APPRECIATE YOU COMING TO
JUST BE A CONSTANT REMINDER TO
US.
HOW HARD IT IS FOR A VAST
MAJORITY QUITE FRANKLY IF
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS? TO AFFORD
TO LIVE.
IN THE GOLDEN STATE AS WE
STARTED OUT BY ACKNOWLEDGING
THAT BY MISTER HUGH IT OUR LAST.
PUBLIC COMMENT THANK YOU.
ALARMING NUMBERS ON THE
MAYWEATHER LOCAL MANY OTHER CAN
MY HELLO MY NAME IS ANNA I'M
HERE FROM THE CAL M<c.cyan></c>
COMMUNITY.
HE ESTARá UP THE MAN CAM ALSO --
ABOUT THE MENTAL SO LAME DOES
THAT I WAS IN THIS FINAL OF
PERSONALLY MY UNIT UP COULD NOT
BE IN IN A HONEST THAT'LL
SILICON.
OF WE ALSO NEED APARTMENTS ARE
HOUSING --
FOR SENIOR CITIZENS THAT DON'T
HAVE LEGAL STATUS.
INCUMBENT BUT UNLESS OF COURSE
ON THE FIFTEEN AND YOU'VE GONE
THIS CAPACITY THAT.
KAMALA SO YOU'LL IMPLICATE.
AND ON THE YOU'LL BE POLITE AND
UP HELP US IN GETTING HOUSING
FOR PEOPLE THAT HAVE --
CHILDREN WITH DISABILITIES WHERE
I COME FROM IT'S VERY EXPENSIVE
AND WE CAN'T AFFORD THE RENT --
YES THIS MESSAGE PHOTO.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
EVERYTHING.
THANK YOU ALL FOR EVERYTHING
WELL THIS IS BEEN A RICH
[inaudible]
RICH --
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION TO BE IN
A HEARING WHERE WE HAVE AT LEAST
TWO LANGUAGES THAT'S BEEN
TRANSLATED I THINK IS INDICATIVE
OF THE REALITY OF CALIFORNIA.
AND THE REALITY OF OF OUR SHARED.
ABOUT LOOKING AT THE SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS THAT IMPACT
CHILDREN SELF I THINK THE BILL
THE ONE HIGH LEVEL TAKE AWAY FOR
ME WAS THIS CONCEPT.
SHARED -- BY
OUR SECOND PANELIST THAT.
THAT THAT HOUSING IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING TO DETERMINE
HEALTH OUTCOME I THOUGHT IN MY
MIND IF WE COULD WRITE A
PRESCRIPTION FOR SAFE.
CONSISTENT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
HOW WONDERFUL THAT WOULD BE --
I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU ALL FOR
COMING I THINK IT WAS PERFECT.
OUR TIP MY HAT THE STAFF FOR
SCHEDULING THE HEARING --
ON THE DAY OF YOUR EQUITY --
RALLY.
I AND I HOPE THAT FOR MANY VIEW
THAT THIS MAY BE YOUR FIRST TRIP
TO YOUR STATE CAPITOL.
THAT IT CERTAINLY WON'T BE YOUR
LAST THIS IS YOUR BUILDING AND
WE AS POLICY MAKERS WORK FOR YOU.
AND SO THEY HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO HAVE THIS CONSISTENT DIALOGUE
WHERE YOU EDUCATE US --
FROM ALL WALKS OF CALIFORNIA
LIFE ABOUT ISSUES THAT ARE
IMPACTING YOU AND AND AND THE
SOLUTION TO HELP BRING FORWARD.
ON THIS VERY VERY IMPORTANT.
ANY FINAL CLOSING COMMENTS FOR
MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES.
YES SENATOR CABALLERO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR I WANT TO
THANK EVERYBODY WHO GOT IT VERY
VERY EARLY THIS MORNING. TO BE
HERE.
YOUR VOICE IS REALLY IMPORTANT
TO US AND PARTICULARLY ON A DAY
WERE IT'S IT'S PRETTY WILD AND
WENT OUTSIDE AND I KNOW YOU HAD
TO RALLY OUTSIDE YOU BROUGHT THE
SUN.
AND WE'RE REALLY HAPPY TO TO
HAVE YOU HERE SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
YOU KNOW IT WE'RE GOING TO BE
WORKING ON THIS WHOLE ISSUE.
OF HOUSING.
AND WHAT WE'LL DO IS ASK YOU FOR
PATIENTS.
BECAUSE WE CAN'T GET HIM BUILT
TOMORROW.
BUT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE CAN AFFORD TO LIVE IN THE
HOUSING THAT THEY THAT THEY LIVE
IN.
AT THAT THEY CAN STAY THERE AND
THEY DON'T HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT
HAVING TO EITHER BE MOVED OUT.
OR LOSE THE ABILITY TO BE ABLE
TO I THINK SO PLEASE WORK WITH
US -- AS THE
CHAIR SAID MY OFFICE IS OPEN --
I WANT TO WORK WITH OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE DOING EVERYTHING POSSIBLE
TO HELP PEOPLE SO THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE TODAY.
THANK YOU AND CENTER HER TOTAL.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
I JUST WANT TO THANK THE
COMMUNITY --
FOR YOU KNOW FOR SHARING YOUR
STORY WITH US HERE TODAY AND
FORTY ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE --
HELPED WITH MAKING SURE THAT
THAT THEIR VOICES ARE HEARD BUT
REALLY I ALSO WANT TO THANK --
SENATOR MITCH MITCHELL FOR HER
LEADERSHIP --
ON THE SELECT COMMITTEE AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING MORE
ABOUT.
ABOUT SOME OF THE ISSUE THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE NEED TO A
DRASTIC THROUGHOUT OUR STATE --
WE WILL BE HAVING A HEARING IN
THE CITY OF FRESNO IN JULY.
I REPRESENT --
PARTS OF FRESNO COUNTY KERN
TULARE AND KINGS AND SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO HEARING FROM ALL OF
YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND WITH
THAT TODAY'S HEARING IS
ADJOURNED